joe biden just delivered remarks
on the tragedies that hit this country
in the past couple of weeks and he uh
i'm just going to come out be a little
bold on it he basically called for
banning guns he said uh banning assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines
their definition of assault weapon in
high-capacity magazine includes like
your standard glock
he also said he wants to end the 72-hour
release period for background checks and
expand background checks to private
sales which would in my opinion for the
most part
lead to
outright banning of all guns
if you don't know a lot about this you
might just hear what he said that sounds
reasonable pete you know what he goes
if you after 72 hours whether the
background checks done or not you get
the gun
yes that's because otherwise the
government has the right to just not
give you the gun which is a violation of
the second amendment if they get rid of
that
the fbi can just look at your background
check form and say
i'll get to it when i get to it and then
two years goes by and they're like sorry
we never completed your background check
i can only imagine that would result in
lawsuits we'd probably win those
lawsuits but i'm watching the speech
from biden and it was just infuriating
because this man
is lying through his teeth blaire white
corrected me when i tweeted that saying
dangerous
i'm pissed off
so we have this story we also have
another story which is interesting and
the source is interesting too it's a
survey
a study done by the southern poverty law
center which i don't trust
but found that the largest demographic
or i should say that the the one
demographic that's overtly uh supportive
of revolution and uh political
assassinations are young democrat men
so when i saw that i was like wow i
didn't think that the southern poverty
law center would want to malign their
own target audience so
maybe this this this survey is legit but
i say this take it with a grain of salt
you know these non-profits they're
trying to shock you and scare you so
that you give them money like here's the
problem look what's happening but they
found that around half of this country
fears a civil war is coming
uh more so among republicans less so
among democrats but young democrat men i
believe were the only demographic that
the majority or should say the plurality
supported
political assassinations that's crazy
there's a large large amount of support
for revolution and political violence
and then here's another thing that also
comes out of this which is it's kind of
a different story but the same survey
young men don't like feminism
young democrat men young republican men
young republican women all said feminism
has done more harm than good so we'll
talk about that too joining us to talk
about all this is tyler fisher hey
who are you good sir uh who am i that's
a good question man uh i don't know i
went through a breakup last night
speaking of feminism so i discovered
myself on a six-hour car ride from
brooklyn new york um who am i who am i
who am i uh well i'm a comedian i'm an
actor i'm a content creator
and i'm trying to navigate this uh this
new fun
cancel culture situation you're in a
movie
i mean i'm in a movie yeah thanks to uh
daily wire uh yeah i'll be in terror on
the prairie which comes out june 14th on
the daily wire cool with gina carano
absolutely and uh excellent yeah
incredible awesome man all from the
internet yes this should be fun thanks
for hanging out we also got chris carr
yes sir thanks for having me back yes
awesome who are you i am the executive
dir uh executive editor almost an
executive director but that's a that's
an overstatement executive editor of the
newsroom at timcast.com right on doing
great work what are you
i i'm still figuring that out i'm i'm
right there with you tyler you will he
him my gosh man she is still a he him if
you can't figure that out then just take
your best guess you know something that
biden said also when we were listening
before is that the the gun or the gun
industry needs to be stripped of their
immunity that they're the only industry
in america that has immunity and it's
like he's the second time he said it on
his campaign speech slash state of the
union whatever you want to call it he
said that it also and he's leaving out
the pharmaceutical companies that have
immunity from damages
just straight up lie straight up was he
joking because it was a joke that's what
it
a joke a is
man were you guys watching the
sign language person you can't have such
a high-energy sign person next to him he
just looks
deader
he's a bad dude
his son lied on a background check for
him to get a gun
and then uh it got disposed of in a
dumpster which is just so so illegal
next to a school okay okay joe anyway
lydia's here too yes i was watching joe
biden's remarks as well which way do i
need to scoot here there we go um and i
was noticing that he's trying to turn
gun rights into a voting issue i think
he realizes this is all he has so i'm
curious how this works out for him uh
he'll do anything considering gas just
hit a new record of 4.71
if you want to round up 72. so yeah he's
desperate ladies and gentlemen before we
get started head over to what is a
woman.com
subscribe to the daily wire this is
actually a paid promo spot today's
episode of the podcast is sponsored by
what is a woman from the daily wire and
i have no problem saying i've been
saying it all day since since i saw it
it's an amazing documentary let me just
say creatively
they it's the editing is fantastic the
pacing is wonderful the music everything
about it was just very very well done
the way they have there's some like
scripted elements to it that like drive
the narrative and then there's the real
interviews which is the bulk of the
documentary it's just really really good
this is a must-see and i got to tell you
you need to you you need to sit down
with those who disagree with you and ask
them to watch it and then have a
conversation about it because the things
being said by these experts we'll talk
about this later in the in the show too
a pediatrician saying a pre-pubescent
child can get medical transition drugs
if they want
matt walsh
i don't want to spoil this for you but
when he he references what these drugs
are used for it's it's a shocking moment
in the documentary so
um i don't even know why the daily wire
paid us to promote this because i've
been shouting out how amazing it is for
since it's like since they gave me the
screener anyway but i'll take their
money so daily wire guys i'm a big fan
this is amazing i am absolutely jealous
what is a woman.com i'm sure many of you
have already seen it by now share it
with your friends have them watch it
matt walsh addresses some of the most uh
important and pressing concerns that
we're seeing in our culture
the the the
sterilization of children
it's brutal stuff blind adults adults
and adults
what is a woman.com man definitely check
it out uh also don't forget head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
from the tim cast irl podcast we will
have one of those up for you tonight at
11 p.m they're monday through thursday
and they'll be supporting our
journalists people like chris who's
sitting there exactly yes keep it up yes
he works because you guys believe in the
work we do so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends let's
talk about this first story joe biden
just addressed
gun violence and uh i'm just i'm really
pissed off guys
biden calls for ban on assault weapons
and new red flag laws the president said
the measures were not about taking away
anyone's guns he also acknowledged that
congress might not come to a consensus
even as the nation grieves the victims
of several mass shootings okay let me
just say this i hope you failed joe
biden i hope you failed because you are
a liar you you are manipulating people
and to anybody who liked what joe biden
had to say i ask you a simple question
what is an assault weapon
what was he talking about banning
bayonets
if you matt walsh's next documentary
what is what is that that's actually a
good idea
we're doing that great idea okay
nobody knows what it is okay what is a
woman nobody knows in this segment is
brought to you by assault rifles yeah
well that's 10 percent
[Laughter]
i mean if they do what is an assault
weapon that actually that actually is a
really good idea because they don't have
a definition and this is what really
bothers me is when he lies
the closest approximation is assault
rifle assault rifles haven't been uh
you can't manufacture i could be wrong
about all this but i'm pretty sure you
can't manufacture them after 1986 for
civilian use in order for a civilian to
buy one it's got to be pre-1986 and it
takes you about a year to get because
you've got to get text fingerprint
you've got to file uh uh the it's it's
through the nf so you've got to file atf
forms
i i've i have uh i i can't do it i'll
tell you why i am too busy
so the amount of work required to
actually jump through the hoops to get
an nfa item an nfa regulated item
national firearms act is just
prohibitive for even someone like me
unless i want to take time off work so i
can go down to the sheriff's department
get my fingerprints and all that i'll
tell you what the craziest thing is
first of all red flag laws are insane
and this i got i got to give a shout out
to maj toure and black guns matter when
he says all gun control is racist that's
right what do you think these police
will do with red flag laws with a red
flag law it doesn't matter if you even
have a gun it gives them powers to
violate your fourth amendment rights
they will come to your house and say
we're searching a warrant on a red flag
and the guy's going back but i don't
have a gun well we don't know that for
sure
don't give the police these powers but
more importantly
what really
triggered me i was triggered well said i
was ringing and i was it was pretty bad
swinging my arms get this gun control
off my country it's really bad when he
said he wanted to end the 72-hour
release for background checks for those
that don't know if you want to buy a gun
you have to get a background check i do
let me just write this down write this
down i live in brooklyn new york oh you
can't get this off forget it the
response time is 72 hours for police so
all right
so now they want to ban body armor check
it out you go to the store you walk up
and you say i'd like to buy i like to
purchase this this weapon why why for my
my own personal reasons to defend my
home for a sport or
to protect this country from enemies
both foreign to domestic whatever it is
is your fancy right it's your right
you got to fill out a knicks form
it's it's it's it's not that big a deal
to fill out the form
then they submit it and you have to wait
they're running a background check
the first time i bought uh uh a gun
they told me you are delayed and you
will have to come back
we'll let you know when you're cleared
72 hours later i got a phone call saying
you are now cleared
i went in and i was able to pick up the
weapon
turns out they never actually did the
background check my understanding is
that
it went long and so my rights as an
american citizen under the second
amendment
i get to take the weapon
if they get rid of that that restriction
on the government you're going to have
federal agents they're going to say you
know we just don't like this james
o'keefe guy huh
we'll do his background check when we
when we get time
and then three months goes by and you're
like where's my background check and
they're like we're working on it
that's what joe biden wants to get rid
of that would give the government the
ability to effectively ban all the guns
at a whim whenever they so decide
and of course they'll give you every
excuse they'll say you know we're just
backlogged and so understaffed sorry you
know what they did with marijuana back
in the day
what they did was you needed a tax stamp
if you wanted to buy it then they
stopped issuing stamps effectively
making it illegal bypassing people's
constitutional rights this is what they
will do joe biden wants to he wants
universal background checks on all sales
including private sales which means you
can't even transfer a weapon to a family
member if you're say you're you're jim
bob and and billie jean out in the
mountains of west virginia and you're
like i'd like to transfer this weapon to
you because i'm leaving and we got
critters and bears or whatever can't do
it gotta drive to an ffl and you gotta
fill out the background check form and
then oopsie
the feds have decided they're not gonna
do it
that's how they ban guns so no no joe
biden screw you you're a liar is he more
serious when he's screaming or
whispering do you guys can you guys tell
the difference i don't know because i
agree
notice he'll start with the yell and
then he'll end with the wizard where are
you guys because you're raised
[Laughter]
he got it from obama
and so does beto o'rourke he does like
owen wilson is uh training him i mean
come on
i think i think it's actually uh the
reason he whispers
is because when he loses where he's
going and he can't think it gives him it
gives him an ex a justification for why
he pauses yeah so he'll be like you know
we gotta
ban the guns like it's like i was gonna
say oh i got it i got it
and then he says something low so it's
like the pause was supposed to be drama
as opposed to dramatic instead of just
sad he can't emphatically say what he's
saying because he's reading it he
doesn't really believe it or really
understand it so then he appeals to tone
he'll try and do a begging tone like
this
yeah because he thinks maybe the tone
will get them because obama did that he
used to do that a lot it was really
insidious but obama was a better actor
you can probably speak to this point
like joe when biden speaks it's just
like wow he's an awful actor and he has
no grounding and principles or morals or
any ethics
yeah
a white guy i can't do an impression of
a complete idiot yeah so um yes we would
discourage that can't do the obama one
can't do eric adams either
oh man
joe biden whenever he gets mad it's it's
so obviously performative
come on man yeah you know it's just like
bro i can tell you're not really
indignant man or jack either one jack
manager check it's like the fakest
it's you're phoning it in dude he throws
his hands up a lot
remember when he got mad at that uh
that guy who was a union worker who was
like you're trying to ban my guns then
he got really angry and started yelling
at him he like punched the guy he'll let
go up and he tried to like jab him yeah
and joe biden's a bad guy
yeah he's a bad guy hangs out with some
bad boys
he's a mean fella wow he's so
unremarkable too
somebody asked me recently they were
just like what would you ask joe biden
if you could interview him and as a
journalist i really pondered on that i
was just like man what would i ask joe
biden i really couldn't muster up a good
meaningful question because i feel like
his record is so unremarkable and so
uninteresting that i feel like i would
just be better off trolling him at this
point in his life even though that might
be considered a little bit mean i'd
never heard of him until he ran against
obama and i was like this is the this is
the establishment character they're
using to run against obama more than
hillary i was like who is this well that
was an old dude i thought he was a
plagiarist from the 80s and had to
resign from this presidential run
basically
the idea with biden was will america
elect a younger black man
so they were like let's get an older
white dude
and put them together so we can try and
maximize our potential and then it's
funny because mccain went with sarah
palin right they were like
let's try a woman and it was just like
yo get the pandering out of there it's
not albany although i think sarah palin
was way better than mccain was so easily
she definitely helped his campaign for
whatever it was but he loses anyway
mccain kept saying my friend he'd keep
calling people my friend all of a sudden
as soon as he started campaigning like
these aren't your friends dude she's
like my friend i really like you you got
to blow up a bunch of people in the
middle east and i was just like i don't
want to vote for that guy and then obama
was like i'm gonna
and the wars and i was like i'll vote
for that guy that's a good obama yeah
but then as soon as he did he's like i'm
gonna blow up these kids
so i'm uh president and uh i blow up
kids you can't steal you're stealing
that impression from a black person
you're taking somebody's job you can't
do that tim yeah come on well actually
hold on i'm not joking i'm i'm mixed
race and mixed race is the smallest
minority in the country so i'm actually
the most depressed oh i'm sorry man
write that down you can write down make
sure you make sure you take note of that
i love how they're listing the you know
it's like the first openly gay
black press they don't do that for any
of the crappy jobs right
the first
gender queer genderqueer ambiguous you
know ambidextrous janitor no one gives a
crap about
any of the mundane jobs at the white
house great if they could like mop with
two hands at once
yeah really useful that's why yeah
you know and and to be fair
it's probably because they're already a
bunch of trans abled you know demi
janitors or whatever right but you know
i think it's a fair point to be like we
got to respect the trades and you could
and society just literally doesn't do it
so if they did come out i'd actually
respect it more if they were like our
school hired the first gay janitor i'd
be like no all right but when they're
like this highlight them keep an eye on
them
when they come out and they're like this
hype you know they they say like this is
the first official or whatever and then
they ignore the republican ones
it's like was it wasn't like the first
republican member of a black member of
congress like in the 1800s and for the
democrats it was like 1992 or something
like that
i thought when they when tulsi gabbard
was running for president uh in this
last cycle and they were like well we
can't we can't cast her as the role
because we need a woman of color
i was like okay
she is a woman of color the the the
shark has jumped like we we just lost it
they they it the shark has jumped yes
shark has jumped everybody remembers
when the shark jumped over the phone
that's right yes
yeah apparently that's when the show's
gone too far it's lost the plot it's
gone like right if you wanted a woman of
color you had a woman of color you
pretended like she wasn't a woman of
color because you want an authoritarian
and is what you're saying and you just
want to use the color as an opportunity
not enough color yeah well i love it
they're like
you know we need more representation for
marginalized voices and then candace
owens is like i'm going to do a popular
show and they go not you
yeah yeah you're out no you're a white
supremacist or larry elder it's just
like
no they really it's funny because they
throw all these racial slurs at um you
know like
candace owens or larry elder
calling i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
repeat the words they use
but they but they'll call them like the
token or whatever that republicans will
rely on and then literally all they do
is that they bring about these these
marginalized voices who just
repeat their own opinions for them
it's funny because you can actually have
like candace owens argue with someone
but then you'll have
these like um
diversity candidates for these these
public jobs espousing mainstream
opinions as if they're being puppeted by
these corporations
that's them doing exactly what they're
claiming the right is doing
projection is
it's
you know what i really hate saying it
because it's like the 800th time will
have said it but they project everything
what's it yeah it's like why am i why
why am i looking up to like candace
owens and larry elder to to like
speak up for you know
like for white men really yeah i mean
like that's really what happened though
like i i was like why am i getting uh
why why do i feel like candace owens has
my back
more than the president or somebody and
they'll go well they're just a white
supremacist like what
is happening right now
a black person could be a white
supremacist
well it's incredible i think they're
conflating it with roman supremacy i
brought this up a couple of times they
call it white supremacy make it a race
thing but like the roman culture
enslaved most of the world that they
could get their hands on they built the
roman catholic church to mentally
enslave people and like it's
predominated our society this roman
catholicism this roman now it's like the
british government with their banks
their international bank like it's all
kind of now we're talking residual of
the romans
seamus is sitting at home and he's going
oh yeah
i got you i love it
defend yourself james is not here to to
push back on the religious stuff i don't
know about all that um but i see what
you're saying right the the roman empire
falls then you get the european empires
the various nations the holy roman
empire that was like germanic but then
you end up with colonization from a
variety of european powers after this
after that you know the empire falls so
ultimately i don't think they have any
idea what they're talking about i think
they're just saying things that use
morsels of truth to manipulate you and
so they can gain power yeah racism
right they know that we all don't like
racism they know that the average
american does not like racism so they
use the fear of you being called a
racist it works well i don't think it's
working so much you know no no yeah
people aren't having it it happened in
2016 i was trying to explain hillary his
email dump to wikileaks to my friend and
he was like uh it's just your white
privilege and i didn't know how to
defend myself
i don't think so i'm just reading it you
felt yourself felt so dirty i was like i
don't have anything welcome in l.a
anymore
there's a real simple uh thing that i
live by and it's just if you don't know
ask
so if someone's like this is your white
privilege i'll go oh what is it what's
that yeah yeah and then they'll say
something like
because you're white x y and z
and then ask them again be like
you know what do you think about poor
people like what do you think about poor
white people just keep asking them
questions to make them answer the
socratic method essentially and then
eventually when they break their own
logic they're just like i don't know
and you know it's i don't know what do
you mean by that
and then
you'd lightly argue with them be like i
don't don't i don't know about that one
he was like it's her time ian it's her
time
and i was like you're just it's your
white privilege yeah i'm like what does
it have to do with her i thought i was
like is it my male privilege or wait uh
i digress here's what i do
you know it's if times are definitely
changed now where we we've bifurcated so
much politically that i don't know if
these methods work but when i would have
people say stuff like to me like about
hillary i'd be like
what do you mean by it's her time and
they'll be like well hillary's been in
government for so long blah blah blah
and i'll be like oh do
you think that makes her a good
president like you think she'll be a
good president and then just have a mask
like ask him these things and then once
they start getting angry the way like
i've experienced that too i always just
be like i'm sorry man i don't i didn't
mean to make you angry depends what you
mean and then they gotta calm down yes
what do you mean by the word word but
the one thing
the one thing i always like is like
if you're asking
questions because someone's making these
outrageous statements they don't mean
anything and then they get really really
angry you just say i don't understand
why you're being so mean or i don't
understand why you're yelling at me
yeah rather than continue to try to
drive home what i was talking about
about the emails i should have started
asking about his feelings and stuff
that's so tactic if someone's using an
emotion if someone's emotionally enraged
they're not going to think straight
their their logical centers in their
minds are shutting down the emotions
taking over and now you want to ask them
like
yo are you all right
like are you mad i'm sorry why are you
being mean that's right it's the same
psychological tactic that you want to
use with children you know because like
you have to use child psychology to deal
with children and oftentimes adults
behave like children so you want to use
the same
techniques of a psychologist that deals
with children to deal with adults that
are behaving like children right and i
know that this is true not because i
have children but because i saw a tick
talk about it
and also reverse psychology yes so when
someone says they want to vote for you
know joe biden you go uh well
i already voted for joe biden and you
disagree with me and then they'll go i'm
not voting for joe i'm actually voting
for trump's like
all right
and that works too no that never works
but that i love that
technically in some areas it literally
did work there's that babylon beam joke
where they said ingenious move trump
comes out in support of impeachment so
that democrats must oppose yeah again
because that's what they did trump could
come out and be like pancakes are great
and they'd be like pancakes are terrible
they're racist the racist history of
pancakes
[Laughter]
there's 400 genders there's so many yes
we're all polyamorous we're all fluid
yeah
they say sure we're fluid we're so
fluent and then they'd come out and be
like we're all straight now yeah yeah
yeah perfect i just want to say you're
like four for four or five for five with
the impressions like i mean i i'm not
keeping track or anything but i think
you're for can you tell what i did in my
room growing up with all my weight shame
i just like well i guess i'll talk to
myself did you do it in a mirror oh yeah
no yes oh yeah jim carrey did that a lot
[Laughter]
all right six percent
that was good but i just don't like jim
carrey yeah
i like him these days what kind of
millennial are you tim i thought you
were a millennial with the rest of us
you don't really know
yes he's he's he's he's like a
self-righteous arrogant guy he's spoken
oh no his brain has been broken he did
speak out in the 90s he meant a lot to
us bruce almighty was awesome yes yeah
and then they did evan almighty and i
was like wow that was good i mean dumb
and dumber's my favorite movie of all
it's just good i thought the ace ventura
was definitely a home run yeah that was
nothing had come out like that
now how are we talking about jim carrey
well he he talks smack about will smith
when he popped um chris rock at the
oscars and he was like came out publicly
and was like it's yeah he's you know
derided it basically it was nice to see
a celebrity do that an actor yeah yeah
you know you know what i prefer is like
i i like people who
are willing to be like wow i didn't know
that
um that that's about it and so like
seeing seeing so many celebrities come
out
talking big acting like they know
everything and they don't they're making
everything worse it's frustrating
because the way i describe it is like
imagine you're trying to fix an engine
actually we talked about this with one
of the progressive guests and then
you've got a guy standing next to you
yelling that you've got to like you got
to put the engine fluid in the blinker
fluid and you're like that's that's not
a thing there's no i saw it i i know you
you're you're insane okay we need and
then they all vote we vote we pour the
water in that valve and you're like
you're gonna break the engine and they
do and you're like
i needed that engine too man
along those lines last night we were
talking about the johnny depp amber
heard thing i want to touch on it really
quick because i said some stuff i said
like just a couple of drunk cokeheads
beating each other up and people like
ian
johnny depp wasn't beating her up i
didn't really follow the trial it
probably did come off kind of ignorant
to speak with that kind of authority and
amber hurt is definitely a liar so i
want to get that on record she said that
she donated money to charity when she
had actually actually pledged the the
money yeah and then when they caught her
on the stand lying under oath they're
like you said you pledged it but you
didn't donate it she's like so did you
did you donate i pledged it yeah i
pledged it that's not what i'm asking
i'm asking if you donated it i pledged
it
i pledged it yeah i don't i pledged it
she was like i use those words
interchangeably and she keeps a
permanent pouty face i don't think she's
just the whole
whole
it was fun he's he's fat he was
fascinating to watch i thought you're
gonna say he was fat yeah
i was gonna agree that's all i took from
him no so fat he was so fat
i was gonna agree because i was like
looking a little thick you know
but he would do these like 20-minute
stories to get to this crazy thing she
did like and i i woke up in the morning
and i there's a light due outside as a
sauce a small injured crow that knitted
a small
cashmere sweater
when i realized this misheard had taken
a crap into my laptop you're like just
get to the crap in the laptop thing
exciting he's got to build suspension
yeah you think he'll be in like he'll
his career will will have a resurgence i
think him and will smith should be put
into some something
absolutely and uh it's it's like maybe
it should be space pirates oh yeah and
aliens yeah that's cool
you know he was off playing a live show
in london yeah when the verdict came out
he is like jack sparrow at this point he
is yeah yeah yeah no he's in he's in
brando territory i don't know if i'm the
only one that remembers how the
trajectory of brando's who brando was
also a very uh kind of a central figure
in johnny depp's life i think in many
ways he wanted to be brando okay and i
think that depp is pretty much at the
brando point his career because brando
had to go on trial for his sons yeah
there was like a i think there's some
sort of murder trial that someone's
involved in and brando had to take the
stand and in this weird way depp is in
the same position that he's in i think
he's in brando territory he's never
going to recover he was also banging
amber heard brando so i think yeah
yeah all right let's let's jump away
from the funny celebrity stuff into the
depressing distressing civil war all
right great we got the story from the
washington times
distressingly high level of support for
assassinating politicians among young
democratic men i saw this headline and i
went what
what is it no way
and then i looked at the data
and the numbers are comparable to
republican women
[Music]
i was like
why is it that
maybe there's something about
i i don't know because young democrat
women
and young republican men are about
one-third in favor of political
assassination and i'm like yo that's bad
enough yeah that they're right yeah so i
love how they framed this like young
democratic men are in favor and then
it's like 44 said they would uh they
support assassination and young
republican women at 40 percent
and then i was like okay so let me
actually i don't know if if this will
actually work if i can pull up here we
go
it's the southern poverty law center who
i don't trust and is probably wrong but
um
reading through this
the fact that they would list young
democratic men as the most in support of
this political violence i was like
well why would the splc deride their own
donors
you know like
they make their bread their bread and
butter is young democrats
so maybe it's legit and i to be honest a
lot of what they say i think it sounds
absolutely plausible there's a there's a
bunch in this server that they produced
notably about feminism about uh great
replacement things like that we'll talk
about the feminism stuff in a minute
because this is that's also fascinating
but you know the partisan partisanship
and violence part
take a look at this
total approval for assassinating a
politician who is harming the country or
our democracy
44 of younger democratic amendments
that's 50 50 years old oh that's less
than 50 years old
approve
54 disapprove
among young republican men it's 34
approval to 57 disapproval
there's a
decent amount of
young republican men who just don't know
but look at this younger republican
women is 40 to 55. that's four percent
off from the democrats and then younger
democratic women is 32 percent approved
you know i don't care if it's 44. you
take a look at the boomers and the gen
xers
and the support is
under double digits right
among older democrat women nine percent
older republican women 10 older democrat
men six percent and older republican men
six percent
when the boomer generation passes on
the dominant power in society is going
to be overwhelmingly in favor of
assassinating political opponents i
think that these numbers though show
youthful ignorance because as you get
older you realize that violence you
start to realize things about the way
the world works and that you can't just
destroy the thing you hate and expect
everything to be okay
we're talking about 45 year olds ian um
did you get the 45 year olds count as
younger did you get how young was that
that's a problem
how many people they pulled like did
they pulled six thousand fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred people so it's not that
many people too it depends on who they
were pulling the kids might have been on
prozac uh well playing a lot of video
games look i think the bigger issue is
that the southern poverty law center
needs to keep people scared so they can
make money off of them oh right yeah so
that's the first thing they say their
methodology is from april 18th 25th 2022
tolchen research conducted a nationwide
survey of 1500 adults ages 18 plus it
was conducted via online panel the
margin of error for the full 1500 sample
is plus or minus 2.53 percent
maybe well
it's bad timing because i think it was
yesterday the man who attempted to
assassinate reagan was let out of jail
hinckley john hinckley jr yes and they
said we think he's
doing okay that's what they said we
think he's gonna do it you guys ready
for this next part oh my gosh check this
out scared in
another poll total approval for
threatening a politician who is harming
the country democracy
younger republican men 46 approve
of threatening threatening a politician
52 disapprove but only 44 actually
approve of assassination you know that
means
republicans i'm sorry i'm sorry it's uh
34 of republican men approve that means
you've got about 12 percent all bark no
bite yeah they're gonna they're gonna
shake their fist of the politician and
then do nothing but it's the inverse for
younger democrat men 40 percent are okay
with threats 44 with assassination that
means that four percent doesn't want to
give you a warning
they're not going to tell you what they
intend to do now here's the best here's
the funny part the same thing is true of
younger republican women 31 agree with
threats but 40 percent agree with
assassination these young republican
women don't want to warn you before they
yeah firstly who in the right mind would
tell a poll that they want they're in
favor of assassinating politicians
that's insane you're gonna be put on a
watch list instantly if you tell someone
that i would imagine good point ian
which suggests the number is probably
much higher and secondly
uh i had a point i'll come back to it i
don't know what the what the [ __ ] look
at this total approval of for
participating in a political revolution
the the here
this is fascinating
the one group that is most in favor of
of participating in a revolution is
young republican men
i tweeted out 45 i'm getting really
tired of this alien versus villain
narrative that we're going through right
now what i mean is like the weird hero
like the young transgender kid that
feels like an alien in the reality or
superman who's an alien or like a
superhero that's not normal this
non-normal hero versus a blanket form of
evil because when you think there are
things out there that are evil then you
may be willing to destroy them and it's
making people think that killing is the
way to solve things and it's not so
it's a fantasy marvel superhero movies
are fantasy there are no good and evil
thing like it's black and white actually
not black and white
put them in jail
avengers infinity war did a really good
job of job of addressing this
they you know thanos was driven by his
character arc was literally i'm going
i'm doing good right he and and you
actually have that conversation in the
film with captain america when he's like
we don't trade lives versus thanos being
like i'm gonna save the universe
thanos thought he was the good guy and
so uh i watch this really amazing
uh uh critique filmmaker's critique of
infinity war and they said what people
didn't realize is that it's a hero's
journey story same as any other story
but it's about thanos yeah dude to have
the comic right here this is where it
all came from if it's called the
infinity gauntlet and you're right tim
you explained it exactly thanos was
thanos was an anomaly he was he was nor
you know from depends on the perspective
you look at thanos from is whether or
not he's evil
yeah he is
it really works though when they set up
somebody to be just pure evil
i mean i fell for it i was i was what i
was listening to npr you know
two years ago watching cnn literally i
was i was brainwashed because you go
with their evil so it doesn't matter
what we do i probably would have been
you know if they gave away free coffee
or something i would have filled that
out i would have been another
point for the democrats yeah so so what
happened for you how did you one day not
like how do you break out from oh yeah
am i coming out my walk away yeah you're
walking away well i talk i talk to
brandon a lot because we're you know
it's this is what's so funny is me and a
guy like brandon we never would have
talked that's brandon strzok yeah yeah
yeah we we they're bringing all these
people together that would have never
associated with each other and and so
it's kind of bizarre but uh it started
with the uh with the the white shaming
stuff
you know that that was it it was like
take a seat give up your job
sorry we're not hiring white people
we're full with white people at comedy
clubs we're not casting white people and
then slowly i'm like am i supposed to
just give up my life
and they would say yes take a look at
this as part of the same poll the great
replacement they say as you know the
demographic makeup of america is
changing and becoming more diverse with
the us census estimating white people
will be a minority in approximately 25
years generally speaking do you find
these changes to be very positive
somewhat positive somewhat negative or
very negative you know what's funny
what do we have we have 63 percent of
democrats say either somewhat or very
positive and i'm like
there is something deeply wrong with you
if you're like it's a good thing that a
racial group is is being diminished or
whatever now for the people that view it
negatively i have some questions about
why they view it negatively sure but
it's not as bad as people view it pop
positively you know what i mean like if
you're like hey it's kind of a bad thing
that a group of people is slowly
disappearing or whatever i'll be like
okay well let's talk about that
for the democrats they're like this is
good i'm kind of like yeah that's kind
of creepy and racist that's weird well
even the white politicians they're like
yeah we'll be gone yeah that's weird
right
it harkens back to like that they're
trying to they're worried too much about
the skin color and not the not the
ideology of the roman i'm gonna keep
talking about romans it's awesome but
like this roman supremacy thing where
like you know it was started by slaves
slave masters they try and like even i
mean i'm i'm i don't want to hate on the
catholic church
but i do hate on the catholic church
because i can't stand the organization
of power and that you have to have this
authority of a pope that you've got to
go through that's authoritarian if you
want to communicate with god it's within
you is that a pedophile you got to go
through the pope
unfortunately yeah and it was hilarious
pretty good
my thing on the the great replacement
stuff is
you know democrats have talked about
demographic changes and means of
maintaining political power
tucker carlson then mentions they talk
about it then they accuse him of
far-right white supremacist conspiracy
theories and i'm like dude they're
outright telling the splc they they're
they viewed positively that white people
are becoming a minority i'm like
race shouldn't matter
you know what's funny is this survey
didn't have a doesn't matter option
it's like is it good or bad yeah or do
you not know and i'm like it's not good
or bad this is what it is if that's
what's happening you know i don't yeah
we're mixing and mingling it's you know
right right i think it's good for immune
systems to racial diversity is good for
the immune system i believe it is but
ultimately what matters to me is the
values i'm going to put that on my
tinder profile there we go
good
values matter meritocracy individual uh
uh freedoms person personal freedom
personal liberty uh meritocracy i said
that um personal responsibility there we
go that's one yeah those are things
responsibility yeah freedom of speech
the um safety and security and your
person and your property you know the
right to self-defense due process
constitutional rights the fascinating
thing is
they say in this let me see if i can
pull it up
they say
if we hope to secure a multi-racial
democracy and prevent partisan violence
uh our results show this is that a
substantial effort on the part of
activists institutions and government
will be required if we hope to secure a
multi-racial democracy
fascinating
stephen marsh was on this show and he's
the guy who wrote the book the next
civil war which i reference fairly often
and he said within the united states
there is a multicultural democracy in a
constitutional republic he said he
favored multicultural democracy i said i
favor constitutional republic
and i think he's right i think that is
the split the splc is very much on the
side of they say multiracial democracy
but democracy is the real point here
we're not a democracy we have some
democratic institutions like we elect
our representatives but we don't and we
have referendums but for the most part
our government is run by elected
representatives who
represent us
i like the constitution
i like the fact that there is like a set
of rules and understandings as to what
the government can and can't do they
want to get rid of that yeah what they
want is majoritarian rule
whatever we say goes which i think is
nightmarish the splc outright says they
want to secure that
it's never been more clear in my opinion
well they're going after equity we
equality is is out you don't even hear
the word equality anymore you only hear
equity which is forced outcome and
nobody knows what that means no one even
realizes that's what's happening
um right and so you can't you would
never watch a football game if you knew
the score and that's what's happening
that's why people aren't watching
netflix because they know the score they
know the story they know it's going to
be this type of person this type of
person this view this view this view and
there's no surprise anymore because it's
not but tell uh tell it to us again but
this time as trump
well maybe i'll do it as jordan peterson
it's like it's like no one knows about
equity tim it's like personal
responsibility
clean your room eat a lobster yeah now
cry cry can you muster out a tear
it's like you got to stop doing cocaine
off a stripper's butt it's like girl you
carl you i don't even know how he came
up with that it's like a miracle tim
even came up with that see i could be
the executive director sheamus is going
to regret not being yeah
it would have been great because we
could have this is my snl audition
because i can't get one so i hope
they're watching we could have had
jordan peterson debate ben shapiro yeah
that would have been fun
terrific yeah i think you made a good
point tyler about equity and about
equality of outcome which is basically
what equity is that they will need well
i knew i'd have that outcome it's like
you said it in a game of football if the
per the team that was leading no longer
got the ball until they until the other
team scored and got there no one would
watch that sport no one's watching you
can't even call it a sport at that point
it's because they're not not able to
compete evenly this is and this is
poisoning every industry because i i
mean i talk about this a lot you know on
social media and stuff and and uh i'm
sure we'll talk about the lawsuit in a
bit but people reach out to me and every
single
department of every job this is
poisoning and people are quitting
they're because they're like i don't
want to be a part of this people are
managers are being forced to hire people
based on skin color and they're put in
this really really tough situation
you know
and uh and people people are just
it's
i'll be honest right running a company
there there are weird laws that you're
looking at and california's got it crazy
like they mandate on the board certain
like you have to have x amount of women
or something like that
so then
your company is no longer built by those
who are good at the job it's built by
people who fit quotas yeah it is
interesting i think men and women is the
best example of the value of diversity
because i
uh when i have conversations with people
i find that having a woman and with the
conversation is a very different kind of
communication not always but there's
logic which is a very male thing then
there's emotions which is a very
feminine thing maybe and um but when it
comes to race like i'm interested in
hearing people's backgrounds and these
other cultures maybe they're from
another country
i think it's way less
important i don't know when it comes to
diversity hiring women like i'm glad
you're here lydia i like that to hear
your perspective
oh i didn't see lydia i didn't know they
put her on the screen all the time
is that offensive of me to say lydia no
that i'm in the corner no no just that
there's a value
a value of like male and female
diversity
absolutely right and we know that women
like people this is why women do jobs
like these school teachers and nurses
and men are engineers turns out
engineering earns more money because
it's more precise and even men when they
go into nursing they go into nurse
anesthesia which is it turns your
patient into an object because they're
completely asleep and then the men take
over exactly yeah that's what earns the
most money yeah it's the engineering but
you're entirely correct ian yeah there
is a lot of value there especially
between men and women and what different
genders tend to offer but however you
have to understand that there are
there's an equal distribution of
incompetence i think across genders and
once you factor in race i i it becomes
very strange but i do think there are
some value to men women ratio generally
speaking i got an idea yeah it's a
stupid idea but i think it's worth
filming yes starting a new company
and
intentionally having the corporate ethos
anti-meritocracy
so we intentionally hire the people who
seem to be the worst at the job
and maybe that's next we'll pull like a
george costanza and make like the best
company ever yeah oh my god i love that
family member opposite do the opposite
i'm pretty sure like we'd start a
sandwich shop and we'd hire all people
with no experience no drive and it just
burned down just call it good looking
good
company
let me jump to this next story it's part
of the same survey actually but speaking
of women ian oh yeah 2x chromosomes have
has this uh post
a study has found that a majority of
democrat men under 50 and a super
majority of republican men under 50
agree with the statement feminism has
done more harm than good boom keep that
in mind as we see roe falling femicide
increasing and birth control coming
under attack to little mainstream
fanfare i jump back to the same splc
poll that we had and i jump down to
gender identity
and they say
uh gender roles and gender identity
agreement that quote feminism has done
more harm than good
46
of young democratic men that's the
majority of young democrat men saying
more harm than good that one was
surprising
23 percent of young democrat women
unsurprising
52 percent of young republican women
think feminism has done more harm and 62
percent of young republican men think
it's done
more harm
that is not surprising the republicans
but the fact that young democrat men
think feminism has done more more harm
i would say is mostly surprising until
you factor in the fact that many of
those young democratic men are probably
incels and i'm not saying that as a
pejorative and i'm not saying that uh to
drag them i'm saying literally there's
probably a large proportion of young men
in general regardless of political
affiliation who have not been able to
start a relationship or have sex and so
they blame feminism well the democrat uh
men are dating democrat women that's
exactly what they're merely going to be
the feminists so they're the ones that
are probably when they're when they
reach 30 and that's what happened to me
that was another part of my
i'm going i'm going on dates and i'm
getting lectured and told i'm a piece of
crap and i'm the problem and then the
check comes and i'm like and then you
know they just sit back and i go oh so
you just want the good parts yep of
feminism and that i found that across
the board and eventually i'm like well
i'm out sorry oh yeah i've had i've had
dates in my life where it was obvious
that chick just wanted dinner oh yeah
strong feminists just wanted dinner yeah
well they got it they got a uh oh but
i'll fuel up but i've i've always been
about gender equality so i just always
split the bill yeah yeah and the bill
comes and they would be like thank you
and i'd be like yeah you can you want to
do your card or should we do two cards
or what you want to do and they're like
wait what normally what are you thinking
here dude the last person i dated she uh
she insisted i pay every time and i
started to just feel like a sugar daddy
you know
uh but then she got a in kind like it's
like the dude from mad men you know yeah
she's like all right babe come on you
know well they're they're picking yeah
they're kind of pick and choose the best
traits of feminism and uh
i mean you know good on them i'd do that
you know if i could i understand if i
get a free meal paying for the woman and
her food and her comfort if she's
raising the child because you need her
body to be comfortable see that's where
you run into the problem because me and
this uh person she was going for her
career full force and i was going for
mine i'm the bread winner you know uh
and so we came to this point it's like
well she's not gonna stop and i'm not
gonna stop so we're never gonna settle
down but i'm gonna keep paying and then
eventually it's like well how long's
like how long is that gonna last ian
say you're a chimpanzee yesterday yes
what say you're a chimpanzee full of
snakes it's like you're a chimpanzee
full of snakes you really said that yeah
he really said it and you're going to
rescue your father from the belly of a
woman right
he's been a huge influence on me he was
one of the first people i heard talking
about this stuff and i would literally
cry watching being like
wow i can actually talk about this yeah
that's why he got so big he was like a
father figure to a lot of people oh my
god
changed my life i mean like i got into
therapy got into 12 steps and i i
went from broke to making six figures to
speaking out to you know this is a kid's
suit but it's still a suit
and and and and it's one per from one
person
yeah from one person he would tell you
that others he's inspired of course by
others that came before of course he
sums everything up so in layman's terms
that's his masterful skill he takes all
of this stuff and he puts it in plain 12
rules for life i want to point out this
feminism thing there's a really good
point that the feminists actually made
if you look at support older democrat
women older democrat men
tend to disagree with the statement they
think feminism did uh more good
and older republican women are 50 are
similar to young republican women but
older republican men 42
they made a good point they said the
older generation probably views feminism
more as the right to vote yes and the
younger generation views it as like i
should eat black lives matter burning
down buildings it's the second
generation feminism which is from the
60s which is the revolution the the
all that stuff suffrage i think might
have been the first generation and now
we're at 12th dimensional feminism where
no it's it's a super the whole ideology
exists in a superposition of itself it
does where everything is offensive and
inoffensive and you never know which
word you're allowed to say it's true
yeah well remember remember when we had
richie's mom on and she did not
understand like what was the issue with
feminism now and i was like it's not
like it was when you were dealing with
it because she's 60 something and it's
totally different now than it was when
she was looking at like i understand
having a positive view of feminism when
it was actually seeking equality for
women with men that's totally different
no one disagrees with that exactly
equality of opportunity but it didn't
seek to make women equal like like the
same as men in society's eyes that was
never you know this is the crazy thing
because it's like
do you think if you ask the average
female
do you feel safe walking alone in a dark
alley at night
they'd probably tell you to a greater
degree than men that they do not feel
safe and a guy might be like i don't
know i never i mean yeah i probably feel
a little unsafe but most guys might be
like i never thought about it for
obvious reasons guys tend to be bigger
tend to have more muscle mass and have
more bone density tend to have more skin
collagen or literally do
and
typically are less concerned about these
things women are typically more
concerned about these things
i i think it it's probably jordan
peterson brought this up but
you if you want to figure out the
differences between men and women you
just tell everyone to line up from
shortest to tallest
and then it happens well it doesn't help
me much
how tall are you well i literally had to
change my height to millimeters on
tinder just to trick women oh sucks if
you change your posture you're always 2
000 millimeters this is this is
a millimeter this is true when they they
added a height uh requirement or a
height like um in between you can go
your highest and lowest height of course
all chicks are gonna be like six seven
no one's going down to five two so i
actually don't show up in people's
matches anymore and my matches went down
almost to zero wow
yeah sucks i wasn't fixing my posture
and elongating it and i gained about an
inch and a half perfect yeah your body
you can just i know
what also helps is um
getting uh
quartered drawn and quartered but not to
the point where they rip your limbs off
just to the point where you scream right
yeah
it's really scratched and quartered
just scored they call it scoring the
muscles
yeah
or they do this thing where they'll
break your legs
and then pull it a half inch that's a
good one and then the bones heal so mia
faro did that to um uh uh ronan farrow
um yeah that's true definitely frank
sinatra's she really did that oh yeah
that's not that's not a joke yeah yeah
she really did that yeah yeah she did
the change
four times yeah what yeah that's true so
he has like really long legs and like a
small torso yeah yeah and you know
that's you know what what she did and
nobody's talking about it you should do
it
i just like really long arms yeah and
play basketball yeah slenderman
i actually have a really like do you
have a long torso uh no moderate i have
a long torso moderator so when i'm at a
bar i i would meet women at bars and we
would be you know looking it should be
six feet she'd think i'm her height
she'd get up and she'd just keep getting
up and i would be here
and one time i met a woman on a train
and i had a coat over my legs we hit we
talked for two hours on the metro north
she was six two and i'm five three and
she got up and i just go i gotta cramp i
go just go go out without go on with
that number i was like i was like my
goal would be to get back to her house
with her never seeing my legs wow you
know like i'm in the uber already like
come on let's go away just sounds like
you need some height equity in your life
yeah you do yeah yeah yeah height
privilege that's high privilege yeah
yeah just put your pants in from knee
first
and so then when they see you it just
looks like you're you know like a
wounded vet or something
and then you get up and just you know
get in the wheelchair and then yeah i
got my little service labradoodle dog
swimming you go swimming that would be
that's where that stolen valor no you
don't do that you're already in the pool
when they get there yeah yeah
but height is height is a huge
determination for for um success yep
absolutely let me tell you guys let me
explain
i'm gonna ask you guys a question i mean
i'm people here's the funny thing i took
a picture with charlie kirk and vosh and
like was it charlie like six five yeah
he's really tall squash is like six
three
and they're like they come over and
they're like let's get a picture
together i'm like okay and then i look
at the picture and i'm like dude it
makes me look like i'm five feet tall
so it's funny though because the way we
have the cameras set up yeah people
whenever i meet them they're like i
thought you'd be shorter you know
interesting yeah because here's how it
works
typically when you watch a tv show or a
movie the people tend to look taller
because the cameras are held at chest
height right so from your perspective
perspective then you you're you're
imagining your head is the camera and
you're seeing these people that are tall
so when we have the cameras slightly at
head height and slightly going down
because we have to cross over each other
the people watching
feel like they're looking down at us and
so the assumption is they must be
shorter than me yeah when in reality
it's just the
position of the camera relative to where
the well now that you blew it man now
they know i wonder if that creates an
air of like uh a lack of authority from
us because we seem smaller
maybe i'll tell you let me tell you guys
something let me ask you a question
i used to work in uh street canvassing
non-profits this i'll i'll ask you tyler
yeah i did too actually by the way you
did for charter schools yeah oh cool so
you like walking people and you were
like hey can you give me money yeah well
i was actually i had i broke into the
trump towers this this is a true story
they'd have to sneak in but go ahead so
circle back there were two
characteristics that guaranteed a their
their uh there's one characteristic per
gender each gender has a specific
characteristic that guaranteed they
would do well in fundraising do you know
what that characteristic was for men
height yes had to be yeah so in my
experience working these non-profits for
some reason a good pen yes the guys
the guys who came back typically always
having tons of donations were just tall
and there were some guys who you'd say
were dumb as a box of rocks couldn't
talk their their their way out of a gas
station and they were just making money
and i'm like what do you say to people
and they'd be like oh i just told them
like look you know you got to give money
you know and then they do and i'm like
well this six foot seven guy talking to
people people just do it scary
of the guys that tended to be more
successful and were short they talked
fast and matter-of-factly i like have no
idea what you're talking about nobody
knows what the hell you're talking about
tim yeah now now among women what do you
think the one trait was
that was more frequent among those who
just tended to do really well in terms
of donations i have two hold on it's for
tyler two ideas
i have two ideas too it's their
wait donations from men or women or
anybody well all i know is
people would come back
and i would tend to see tall guys would
make consistent amounts of consistent or
large amounts of money and then there
was a characteristic among women that
these women would tend to come back and
just have money i hate to say it but
boo i'm going to say boobs i'm going to
go and i'm going to say boobies
that is true yeah that's correct well
you can't
take that clip if i'm doing trump's
voice i was going to say intelligence
you tended to see it's not absolute yeah
but women with large breasts
would tend to be like it was easy
i i you know i got five donors and you
know and tall guys yeah we're animals
right we are animals yup and you can't
you can't
separate that from any from these
conversations all of them are it's our
primal instincts but you know what's
funny is the stigma around saying
women's breasts versus a man's height
like men can't control their height
you know what i mean women can't control
their boob size it's it's it sucks in my
opinion that both
you know there's these these determinate
factors yes we can that change right in
your chair
this is me at a bar
i have to order with a sock puppet on
like that's great couple milks here got
a couple milk
but but uh there's there's a uh uh
people are more worried to say is it is
it boobs yeah i was nervous nobody cares
about saying a dude's tight people
people can like these these women can
outright be like i won't date short guys
but if a dude says he's like i don't
date flat chicks they'd be like how dare
you i think genetic realism is massively
important part of the conversation
modern society absolutely it doesn't get
enough attention i'd like it to get more
guys viscerally attracted to women with
large boobs so they want to be
physically near them literally they want
the opportunity maybe her hands going to
touch his hand when he's signing the
paper girls like tall guys because they
have large you know members and
everything or there's an assumption or
racial genetics like someone might have
a darker skin tone because the more
melanin from their ancestors getting
more sunlight things like i love that
stuff yeah i mean look when a man looks
at a woman we're looking at their their
uh waist to hip ratio to really be like
can she crank a couple babes out that
that's what we're doing
it's not that we like big butts we like
to know that they can have kids well the
reason that people like big butts is
because it means that you are likely to
be a better
mother yeah like to be able to have
children more easily and nurse them
that's right exactly yeah butt fat is
associated with health as well okay yeah
it's much it's much better than um
abdominal fat i think the communists
they hate the idea that there is an
element of your life they can't control
yeah right but i always tell people like
look man you can't change the cards you
were dealt but you can you can play your
hand the best of your abilities i've
seen some poker hands where dude's got
seven two off suit but bluffs his way
into winning the pocket yeah i want to
turn him over to jack six when the
blinds are high and it's every handheld
counts you can you can win with a crappy
hand she's got not a player you've got
to know how exactly yeah yeah you can't
change the direction of the wind but you
can adjust your size oh it's
motivational i think short guys are
funnier because that was my that was my
way to get women's attention it was be
the funniest person probably talk the
fast fastest and uh you know so i i see
like a tall guy it looks like me he's
really hot i'd go if i was him i
wouldn't be funny at all you could do it
lord farquaad did remember that when he
had the knight's armor but it was like
his feet went into the massive metal
legs
what i'm doing with my pants right now
suits yeah well i mean it was a comedy
fantasy film so yeah the military's
working on giant exo suits where you can
lift like 10 000 pounds i don't know how
much weight they get but they're like a
thousand pound suits a dude was just on
rogan talking about it damn oh wow we
still require battery packs we're
talking about building a real-life iron
man suit like that's what the military
is working on right now have you guys
seen obi-wan the show no no i i started
watching it even though i was like i
don't like star wars and it's exactly as
bad as you think it is oh no
it's basically just like
remember darth vader
remember obi-wan
it's just like okay did we get it you're
just telling us what we assumed happened
anyway but i bring it up because they
actually show darth vader and like his
limbs are cut off and then he like
you know they attach the things to his
body or whatever
and then you know it is kind of cool
actually to actually see darth vader
going about his business because you
only had the big movie moments right but
anyway james earl jones to doing the
voice still yes he is wow
but um you know i just bring it up
because he had
limbs like he had his prosthetics so you
know he's short but you know now he's
tall
yeah that's a good point everyone's got
a thing everyone's got a thing that that
they suffer from and it's like that that
that's back to the race thing where it's
like you have no idea what anybody's
going through when i was a kid my best
friend was black his grandfather was the
chief of police so the police department
was run by a black family and i wanted
to be him so bad
you know my parents were getting
divorced my dad came out of the closet
life was hell my mom was suicidal and
it's like i wanted to be my black friend
more than anything and it's like
nowadays i feel so bad for these kids
who are going to be born and they are
going to go well i have it worse even
though my life is hell just because i'm
on black or white or vice versa yeah i
think that the damage this is going to
do to children is going to be like just
irreversible it was stark when i heard
that for the first time i don't know it
was probably about four years ago that
because of your skin color things will
be harder that really bothers more
easier yeah yeah like you tell a
five-year-old that they're gonna believe
my life is hard and then they're gonna
start finding problems
to justify what they think yeah
especially in this victimhood uh society
where it's like a billion dollar
business now so
it's so tragic yeah this is some let's
talk about pharmaceuticals for a second
biden totally missed the ball on that
speech he just gave not talking about
pharmaceuticals with kids what do you
think biden's intention is to sell more
to pharmaceuticals
this is why i say he's a bad person this
is why i call him evil he lied
he is trying to manipulate people to so
so they give up their rights
and he's not addressing actual issues
that are screwing people over
i mean you look at these people
in in government and they're just like
what can i do today to screw over
regular people because i want power
and like they're
do you think they're working towards
some sort of profit motive well let me
let me ask you something right let me
ask you guys a question what if the
earth really is overpopulated and
climate change is about to wipe us out
if that were true would you support
taxing gas shutting down pipelines
suspending air travel locking people
down no no ramp it up i'm not going to
kill myself to stop the problem that's
not the way to stop the problem go out
with a bang anytime let's
so you would say if you knew that we
were like let's just say like
hypothetically six months to the
apocalypse unless everything was shut
down now you'd say bring on the
apocalypse
after covet i think if cova didn't
happen that the the lockdowns i'd say
yeah but after that like no i'm not
going through that again i can't do it
nope it's inevitable
there's nothing i don't think that
there's anything functionally that we
could do to actually stop an apocalypse
if it's really that predictable and that
evident that it's coming
there's nothing to break up with her
i think they're lying
and here's what i say
if you seed control to these people when
they come out and they scream this the
sky is falling
they're probably wrong
they're just probably wrong
they might be right science might say a
lot of things but we are but humans we
are not you know omniscient we're not
gods so i can respect when they say
things like we better be better stewards
of the earth and i'll be like okay i'm
down let's do green energy because
that's that makes sense
but when you see power to them and
they're like
suspend population growth which leads to
cultural collapse and civilizational
stagnation and potential collapse when
they say things like they're going to
sacrifice x many people by shutting down
fuel and and you know pipelines and
stuff that's going to result in death
i'm like and if you're wrong
you're actually causing the problem you
are the apocalypse there's two ways to
look at it climate change is destroying
the planet there's too many humans or
we need more humans to continually
expand our scientific understanding
decentralized uh
the decentralized power among the people
will find a solution to these problems
and carry humanity beyond the stars
i i lean in that direction there's no
there's also there's a i forget who it
was on rogan two guys i think who wrote
a book about
population and they said
what's your evidence that the earth is
overpopulated what do you what's the
number it's it's the same thing with
cover there's no limiting factors is it
nine billion ten fifty
it's not that it's overpopulated it's
just that we're not properly dealing
with the resources right and i've never
heard anyone say that until until those
two guys and it kind of blew my mind a
little bit yeah so when totally uh we're
too heavily organized in cities and
reliant on the outskirts of the farms
like if the power goes out and the roads
get blocked the cities get starved
that's the problem that's one of the
hugest problems
decentralized communities with magnetic
trains where you can just travel that's
circular circular cities ruled by
supercomputers like burning man is that
why they're letting everyone get shot in
new york city maybe that's just like
they're letting it get shot
when bill gates bill gates comes out and
he gave a ted talk where he said that
you know we can reduce population growth
by 10 or 15 percent
here's a guy who says we need less
people and what if he's wrong what if we
need more people what if elon musk is
right
pick one you know this this idea when
they come out and they're like we're
overpopulated in climate change and i'm
just like
and if you're wrong
so i i look at this way humans have
continually adapted more people means
more innovation
let's
make a bet on humanity and not
against humanity yeah the connection is
we the people are poorly organized the
amount of people we have right now and
the organization structure that they're
in is not sustainable if if the power
goes out and the roads get blocked
people will have a mass die off in the
cities but it's also true that we need
more people so we need a more organized
structure for those people better
traveled better transport drone delivery
of food things but we do these things
humans
develop these things you know we adapt
to these issues well the whites are
dying out guys i know what you're
complaining about it's all we need ten
years and we're fine oh that's that's a
funny thing too about um white people
becoming a minority because it's like
it's white liberals that aren't having
kids you know what i mean yeah and
that's also assuming like people are
getting together that aren't the same
race because if a white person and a
mexican person get together and have a
baby the baby's not considered white
exactly
so that that's actually how the census
works in this country if a white person
has a kid with someone who's half white
the baby is just not white even though
it's a quarter you know whatever race
yeah you just considered other
interesting yeah but they could grow up
and be called wide adjacent
well that's a that's a political thing i
mean like
as far as it goes with at least this is
what i was what what it was like growing
up they said you're not considered to be
solely white for me because i have you
know asian so it was just like you're
not a white person you got asian yeah
can i buy it can i what can i get i want
to pay you for that man uh i i would
have to extract an offer 25 of myself
it's like yeah haven't they won every
white guy i know does not want to be
white it's like okay you want you guys
won
every white guy's like i wish i had
something that i can just add to my
resume right now i was raised by a gay
man and his partner and i'm like that i
wish that transferred but those credits
don't transfer you know i'm gay raised i
wish i no because it's not my lived
experience that's that's what i'm told
but you've got insight into the lived
experience yeah i grew up in gay bars
but it doesn't matter it's like no one
wants to hear it
interesting
well gay raised because i'm white that's
right yeah even gay there's a lot of gay
white men now who are getting uh
rejected in hollywood and they're
reaching out to me that's i'm like damn
we've really
it's bad yeah not gay enough or not you
know like not quite dark enough oh yeah
that's the best thing it's like
if uh if i come out and agree with them
then i'm a marginalized person if i
disagree with them well you're white
it's like oh so i get to be white if i
disagree with you yeah okay
let me tell the racists over there who
who you know what you said give me
permission to be white that's why i
think that whole ideology is just
bankrupt it's so it's
destructive it's i think it's the number
one thing that'll destroy the country i
got i got to say though this what is a
woman stuff uh the wokeness
it's a great red pill when
what is a woman is the best question
because you you're seeing all these
progressives unable to answer it and
then i'm just like man
all you got to do is go you're like how
do i convince my parents or whatever
they ask them what a woman is
there you go that's terrifying
it's like a simple dictionary question
and it's funny it's it's like people
can't answer it well how can you fight
for a woman's rights and then not be
able to define that's the thing that
everything is starting to contradict
itself the house of cards is just
falling down they've got they've created
they've made up so many terms and
ideas they're starting to collapse it's
fun to watch i think that's what i
thought the uh the flag was the pride
flag there was so many flags on a flag
that it was collapsing on itself i
couldn't tell
it didn't have like um structure the
structure was lost in the madness it's a
perfect representation it's madness they
want it to be madness
that what what the the thing that nets
posted
where it was just like it it looked like
a jackson pollock painting yeah it was
just weird symbol symbols and shapes and
lines and i'm like
that's what i'm talking about that was
the house of a house of flags is that
what this is the new jersey nets is that
we're talking about brooklyn oh the
brooklyn nets yeah and it was like this
weird
do we have that one
a couple nights ago it's a great fight
oh you're from brooklyn oh yeah yeah i
live in brooklyn now yeah i'm sorry
brutal yeah here we got it we got it
right here like yo that's it i even saw
gay guys who were just like i don't
understand what this is it's too crazy
what is it it's too many people trying
to be accepted for something that's
different
and now that's that's chaos in action
right there well they're justifying
every new made up group and then they
have to give the new one their color or
space on the flag there's going to be
that this is going to multiply every
year of course that's so wild it's got a
like it feels like it's collapsing on
itself from the chaos we should make a
flag yeah
what kind of flag i don't know
but everyone else has one i kind of want
one i definitely want one they should
make a flag for biden
trump's got a flag
the biden one could be him sniffing some
glass of milk a glass of milk
pudding
applesauce
a glass of milk yeah that's it dog it
says dog face yeah i love dog facebook
could you make like a flag that's a
prism so depending on how you look at it
you might see the rainbow or you might
you just might see through it a
three-dimensional flag yeah a cube yes
they to stop giving people flags and
parades
it's key it's it's making these people
turn into children
it's got to stop i'm not i'm just not
celebrating it anymore i mean i used to
have to because i grew up right you know
i think we should just give that one
quote a flag with their name on it yeah
yeah because the smallest minority is
the individual that's right right
there you go and the smallest individual
is a baby that's right we should carry
the most babies we should make flags for
unborn children that's right yes
that might solve the birth certificate
problem yeah you know with the
assignments the birth assignment the
gender assignments at birth you just get
a flag instead of a gender assignment
perfect get a selfie they make a problem
picture of it with it in your hand no
names anymore just say yes
yep perfect oh yeah back in the day
before they had addresses they had
shapes and images on every house like
there would be a red shield you know
rothschild the rothschild that means red
shield came from the original guy at a
red shield in this house we're
regressing back to that yeah just shapes
and symbols and emojis i love it it's
like hieroglyphics yeah that's a good
idea i love it i wonder if i could do
that you know like we'll build a house
and then when we have to register with
the post office i'll be like it's the
poop emoji house
they're like we're not right now is
herd's house
i wonder if we could do that that'd be
funny you can you can actually create
streets so there was a property i was
looking at and there was this like
gravel road that just went off the side
and the owner said that
uh he he like sold it to the city or
whatever but he had already had a name
and so it just became like the name
street they left it the way it was and
i'm like so we could we could do that
because i'll create a crazy named street
you know like you know like amber turd
avenue or something yeah hill hill yeah
if you had a city would you name stuff
after yourself if i had a city
uh yeah for branding i think i think
it's a good branding i would do at this
point yeah absolutely
could you imagine like you it's it's the
1600s and you you just you walk up a
hill and you're like i'm gonna build the
house right here
and then they'd be like what's that
place over there and like oh that's
iansberg
because berg is hill right and then he'd
be like oh and then you'd be like yep
i'm ian that's my hill and then everyone
started calling it ian's berg and then
now it's iansberg and then now we have
that
yeah
let's talk about the apocalypse guys oh
good gas prices on the road to five
dollars nationwide very soon um that's
the news congratulations everyone i hope
your vote for joe biden was worth it
it's at 4.71 cents per gallon in
california it's over eight dollars
so uh
you know apocalypse when
apocalypse now no that's a movie yeah i
didn't mean to say that out loud
it was too tempting not to say yeah
you kind of you kind of look like me if
we go through like one more pandemic
yeah
yes and then shave i feel you i feel
like we both spared by we could like
interchange our looks right now yeah
very nicely uh apocalypse i don't know
what does apocalypse mean does that mean
the end of the world we talked about the
people who want revolution and all that
stuff and we can talk about the
political implications of what would
drive actual conflict but it's going to
be this
when people can't afford to go to work
anymore when the cost of getting to work
is more than the work produces people
stop working of course yeah
remember the toilet paper shortage that
was a people were really scared yeah you
know two weeks toilet paper and that was
weird too because i was like just use
your hand and then wash your hands right
are we all doing that
i don't know literally yes
i suggest it uh
it actually feels better too it's less
dry wait i wanted to ask i was joking
i gotta ask him this question tim you
said a number a long time ago uh a
certain percentage of people's income if
it goes toward food that would be the
marker of a revolution what percentage
was that oh i don't remember we were
reading something yeah it depends if
you're dating a feminist or not i mean
yeah that's fair yeah because they eat a
lot 90
because they're like i'm healthy at
every size that's right
and then you're like okay dear okay
and then you're giving them the french
fries so the apocalypse from ancient
greek is a literary genre in which a
supernatural being reveals cosmic
mysteries or the future to a human
intermediary
has that already happened is that what
the internet is
have we created like some sort of super
being yes communicating with us and
making people crazy
don't look at it it's like the ark in
indiana jones
if you look at it
you're like
yeah that's what the internet is the
phone is the arc you turn it on you're
like
in your face that's what twitter feels
like
actually that would be a good kind do
you feel like we're more the reality is
more now the internet than reality i
think we've actually s we've just
crossed the line yeah
well it's the it's the younger
generation
yeah so when you know i say this for
people people don't understand that you
don't convince people to join your side
like it happens it does an individual is
convinced of your argument and then
becomes whatever
you know politics you have what really
happens for the most part is young
people have those values and then grow
up with them
rarely are people actually jumping ship
originally yeah so
you're saying the reality becoming more
like more the internet it's because
boomers and gen xers who grew up in
reality are slowly aging out right once
they're gone and it's all millennials
the internet will be everything right
unless the power goes out i normally
don't i hardly ever say like we need
some sort of catastrophe to show people
what really matters in life i think it's
from time to time but i don't want to
bring that on people but if the power
went out and people have to
that would be missile yeah that would be
it
they would be like fish out of water
they would just like fall down and go
like i was not like yeah even if they
just stopped tick-tock right now
there'd be millions of people in the
street just dancing just like for now
hoping someone sees it it's the weirdest
thing we'd have like a meltdown the
first when tick-tock first started
happening i remember we were in jersey
yeah and i look out the window and
there's some like little girl in the
middle of the street just doing this
weird dancing
and i was like
what's going on and then she just saw
the flag
and then she walks up to a mailbox and
picks her phone up and i was like oh she
was filming herself and i was like what
is this
and then i saw it all over the place
people would be in the malls and they
would just be like standing in the
corner like doing weird and i'm like wow
like listening to hearing songs no one
else can hear it's over yeah it's over
we can't come back from that yo people
are going to plug into elon musk's
neural link to join the metaverse in two
seconds yeah they're going to be bagging
elon musk is going to be like the first
edition of neural link can be surgically
implanted and we'll do it for free just
come over here and we'll jam the spike
in your neck and they're going to like
please heal on me
i want to be in tick-tock
so like live in that reality if we've
got a sort of a cast system set up right
now where you have the really wealthy
people that never think about money
really they never have to even think
about it unless they want to make more
of it then you have like the working
class and then you have the abject poor
now if you have the meta versions
where
are they might be lower than the abject
poor it might actually be considered
abject poor they're just like getting
intravenous you know nutrition and
getting their
harvesting their body heat or something
for
but then it's going to create
a class of like workers that hate
reality but are willing to do it because
they don't want to be part of the lower
slave class like the metaverse class
i think it's going to create another
you guys ever watched battlestar
galactica
yeah
no you've never seen it it's pretty good
so uh one of the best shows ever totally
so i'll give you the short version
there's a bunch of different colonies on
all these different planets
they make these ai robots the ia robots
go to war with them then eventually the
civilization gets wiped out because you
know the robots advance themselves and
then declare war so now all that's left
is like a fleet of ships that are
traveling away from the wiped out
civilization and there are ships that
refine the materials they need for fuel
and stuff and the people who work on
them have no choice and they're
basically slaves they work 80 hours they
don't get time off because if they stop
working the whole thing collapses
they'll die
but then the captain of course he has to
deal with the conflict of struggling to
survive but he's got the nice whiskey in
his office and you know he's in charge
and that's just like that's the reality
of struggle in the real world this is a
documentary about amazon
so
they actually have episodes where it's
like people are trying not to work
because their lives are miserable on
these mining ships or refining ships and
they're like if you stop working we all
die yeah and then they're like we've got
to rotate other people in because people
can't do this anymore and they're like
if they can't do it they can't do it and
we need the people who can
so that's just that's the reality of
existence so if we ever created like an
actual metaverse civilization then
you're going to have some people who are
the privileged elites who are in the
metaverse and the poor people shoveling
mud and dirt outside to make the machine
run with their masks on with their masks
on so you could have classes within the
metaverse of rich people in the
metaverse that can control the code and
see the customer and everybody else yeah
the zuckerberg class they're gonna walk
up to you ian and you're gonna be like
zuck i don't like what you did he's
gonna go beep beep beep and you're gonna
turn into a giraffe he'll like teleport
in and i'll be like i to teleport he's
like if you work your whole life you
might be able to and 40 years go by me
trying and then
no it doesn't happen they'll like
there will be the elite class i mean
it's happening now we don't even it's
not even sci-fi you've got the powerful
elites who can control big tech and
manipulate what you see and hear
to make you think what they want you to
think it already exists you're seeing
this within comedians they're starting
to go all right what was ban on tick
tock this week so what are the things
you have to avoid oh you got to make a
thumbnail like this don't include this
image
a friend of mine his tic tac was just
taken down because he had a picture of a
gun wow wow and it's i'm banned from
there every
every other week we're permaban from
tick tock i've never even got i don't
even know why but it's starting to shape
uh comedy yeah cancel culture is shaping
comedy and everyone's terrified so i
talked i talked to a guy we might have
in the show and the general idea is
they know they can't win on free speech
grounds
so they're trying to control what young
people see in here so that
oh yeah let let tim kesteral have their
conversations who cares they're in their
30s by the time these 15 year olds are
in their 30s they're going to hate free
speech and they're going to do as
they're told
yeah it's
it's launched already it's not free
speech if our speech is getting censored
by corporations at will just because of
what the ceo wants to do that's not
that's not freedom they're getting
people to actually cancel themselves
that's kind of how i think of it yeah
it's because i started to do that i
started to censor myself on stage and
when my with my writing i'm like oh i'm
actually cancelling myself and my
material is getting so boring so people
aren't watching it just do a joke where
you just bleep out the words so keep the
joke but just bleep it
right on
yeah so or on stage so you can be like i
met a guy right he came from this
country a bunch of bleeps you know yeah
yeah that would be a funny joke yeah the
whole thing he's sleeping bleeps you
know these blips this bleep knows what
i'm talking about
he's a little bleepist well you can't
say that because you'll get banned on
the internet for hate speech if you call
someone a bleep yeah
or just carry carry a thing that beeps
and so you're talking about dude yeah
yeah yeah i'm gonna do that
yeah yeah
then you can keep all your jokes i think
you're right about self-censorship it's
one of the more dangerous things that
can happen to someone right now because
it's such an early stage of like
internet censorship still we have an
opportunity you know we're constantly a
crossroads to fix and make these things
better with free software copy left
software yeah but self-censorship in the
meantime is the road to ruin i mean i i
had uh uh millions of views taken off i
did i did a fouchy impression and they
actually called it imitate removed for
imitation what what like this is comedy
what
you were pretending to be dr fauci yeah
i did just him just talking about you
know like the first shot really is just
to loosen up the vein then we did the
third fourth and the fifth shot just to
create a fisa community then seven
through 10 or placebos getting us to 12.
and all of these are removed and they
say removed for imitation now that's
different than impersonation
impersonating someone is illegal you're
not allowed to i'm not allowed to tell
people i'm tim pool and use tim's credit
card like that's illegal yeah if i go on
social media make a tim pool account
they're probably being banned tim
yeah but
my trumps are taken down
so fast like faster than they'd see
pelosi with their eyebrows she does they
won't let you do trump oh trump was
removed last uh two days ago in i think
it was 11 minutes from tick tock wow and
it's like
it's because they don't want people to
enjoy their ccp they they can't handle
the power of goodness no no these trump
impersonations make trump likable
yeah yeah because he's funny right
whatever you would think of him he's
he's actually really funny
but it's so scary that now the the
guidelines on tick tock are 5 000 pages
long same with instagram they can remove
it for any reason they want and they
have so many reasons now where it could
just be removed because somebody got a
little upset oh yeah it's removed
because ccp thinks you're gonna upturn
their communist dictatorship right it's
bite dance is the company that owns it
and that's basically run through the ccp
i've never touched the crap i refuse i'm
um yeah but
tick tock it's trash but it became like
a survival thing for me because my
instagram got shadow band and it's like
take my tick tock blew up and then i
started to tour and then they shut it
down and it's
and people are it's it's re it's a
problem they want to to control the
culture of young people so that they
believe what they want them to believe
and behave the way they want them to
behave and so the people who run these
companies it's a ccp right they're
manipulating us they're attacking us
they're our adversaries
i hate to say it but it blows my mind
it's it's at some point you got to call
a spade a spade like i in 1934 germany i
don't think i would have been happy with
with hitler's rhetoric and i probably
wouldn't have been on on maybe i i
wasn't there i don't know but the the
slaves the uyghurs in in western china
unconscionable i can't deal with it i
own
freaking software that was built by
these people unfortunately
or hardware i should call it but i can't
stand for it man that's that's slate we
still live you guys really care about
slavery and racism turn your eyes on the
ccp no they don't
i don't think anybody just for the most
part they just wanted to move it smash
the ignorance yeah do you know what was
the biggest contributor to the end of
slavery
it was uh
it was it was industrialization yes i
was i was reading about it when
humans
did when when
the easiest thing for a person was to
have a slave they would fight to
maintain that slave
but once industrialization began and it
was actually cheaper to maintain a
machine than a person then you lost
economic incentive the reality was
humans were motivated by money and greed
to have slaves i mean that's fairly
obvious right
so once that was once it was cheaper to
have a machine they were just like you
you lost the support for it and then
abolitionist sentiment started to grow
it's crazy right
people people people assume it was a
moral thing where like humans woke up
one day and we're like you know i've
realized it's wrong what we're doing no
the reality was they were making more
money not having slaves so no one
supported it and then
imagining some guy going is this bad
right
yeah this this plays with what you were
saying about battlestar galactica too
they have slaves because they have to
literally to survive for the ship to
survive they need people to work 80 hour
weeks in the coal mine that's crazy
yours i think your civilization would
collapse at that point like in balance
our galactica when they have these
people in the refining ships or whatever
it was i'd be like no dude people would
probably just lose it
like that
the show is about them adrift basically
with like limited resources
it's one thing to be on a planet where
you can always go off and try and
survive on your own it's another thing
just have be like in a desert with
nothing do you think they'll be able to
convince enough people where it really
becomes the dominant force just whatever
what do you want to call it woke brain
disease whatever it is
but it really is a brainwashing i i feel
like young people are starting to snap
like they just they're they're sick of
it they're sick of
young people are rebellious right and
they don't have lives anymore no one has
a life no one has a relationship or a
house or a good job
so what isn't it yeah yeah we need more
more relationships more jobs more cool
jobs like using lasers to make graphene
so there's i think these blank slaters
who think they can raise people to be a
certain way are gonna have a rude
awakening when they realize that it's a
little bit of nature and nurture yep and
you can't just remove the nature from
people so these young people who are
like on tick-tock they they crave human
affection and attention and they're not
getting it they're gonna snap
and they're going to say the system is
broken i don't want to live this way i
used to think you could get enough for
relationships through internet video
chat and i had a friend tell me like no
i don't think so ian it was like in 2007
and i was i was manic about the internet
the power of internet video i was like
no i mean you can meet these most
intelligent people you know video chat
with them you don't need secret service
there you can it's if this is it this is
the future and it's doesn't compare to
this yeah where there's some sort of you
can smell each other there was no unit
oh i do yeah there's a this is a this is
a a fact
humans are happier around nature yes and
so they actually did controls to
determine people's rated levels of
happiness and they found that
people who live in cities are unhappy
because of the city and if you take
people from cities and bring them into
nature their levels of happiness go up
yep i'm dying inside from from being in
new york i mean it really is dangerous
and it's falling apart right now but uh
it's it's taking a toll yeah yeah no i
i'm plotting i'm plotting there is you
know what i see when i walk outside
chickens yeah and you know what they say
when i walk outside
bach
it's fantastic andrew i think andrew
huberman the uh neuroscientist you guys
familiar with his work huberman labs
he's brilliant brilliantly i dabble in
his work yeah not too familiar he's been
on rogan a couple times at least once
and he has uncovered or has been really
pushing looking into the horizon every
day for like 15 minutes because the
amount i don't know if it's about your
peripheral vision but it's the unfocused
long-distance view is supposedly one of
the greatest things you can do for your
mental health according to andrew i
defer to the scientist on that one in
montana that's where that we shot tara
on the prairie and we just we were in
between two mountain ranges in the
middle of a prairie
and i just stared out into the which
ranges who do you play in the movie uh i
play a guy his name is long hair believe
it or not
yeah long hair and uh yeah he's he's uh
he was in the civil war and uh not on
the not on the correct side oh depending
who you ask
and me um nick circe
um
uh
nick yeah nick circe um heath friedman
an actor who actually passed away right
after the film oh wow and uh daniel day
lewis's son in his first oh wow ever
film gabe and the four of us yeah we're
just seeking revenge and and going after
cowboy cerrone who's not home
but gina's home his wife and then we uh
we spend two hours fighting her oh wow
yeah that sounds fun nice when's that
out a little knocked out june 14th
on the daily wire daily wire cranking
out the hits
yeah they're they're
man i think they are they're actually
going to be a contender for netflix in a
few years yep i agree i think netflix
thinks that too
they're done i mean they're basically
like hey we can't make these did you see
what they said we can't make these
crappy movies like the irishman anymore
i don't know if they didn't use the word
crappy but they're like these pat we
can't use these like ego projects
anymore we're like wow rich people get
to just
ob1
it was like
there was an article i saw and it said
star wars it has a uh like a plot
problem
it's like it's all done it's all written
we know exactly this is gina carano
that's the problem all they're doing
with these shows is like let's just
reuse the same characters oh and i'm i'm
just like if
they tried doing the sequel movies and
they were just total trash
the the industry is decaying just
totally yeah
well i think it's a lot of the woke
ideology thing they're they're just
picking people based on what they look
like instead of their talent or their
audition they're just putting them you
know in front of the chessboard and
daily wire if they keep it up uh i think
they're going to clean up they're not
doing that they're taking that script
they just had three female leads in a
row and they said it's not because we
wanted to have like it was a decision
those were the best scripts that came
across our table and they read thousands
yeah and if they really keep it up i
mean they cast our film i they saw me on
instagram and gave me an audition they
didn't do a social background check
which they do now on netflix and all
these shows wow they just picked the
best auditions
and
the film's incredible i think their
their movies are going to be
people are going to want to see them i
will give a shout out to guardians of
the galaxy because
guardians of the galaxy 1 and 2 i think
are some they're some of my favorite
movies just because they they use the
old soundtrack
so you have this movie and the way they
use the old music and brought it all
back is just one of the coolest things
but it also is indicative of like a
decaying culture where we have
like
i think because of guardians of the
galaxy all these old songs from the 70s
reach top charting positions and i'm
like it's cool because the music was
better in a lot of ways back then in my
opinion even though i wasn't around for
it yeah
you know some of it was
i mean crosby stills nash and young four
dudes singing four-part vocal harmony
for the recording but they went nuts
well young did neil young yeah
neil young is a pretty special man hey
you i we're gonna go to super chat soon
but i wanted to ask you like you said
you were basically bankrupt in like
abject poverty then you now are making
six figures because of peterson but like
what was that transition like for you
well jordan gave me a hundred thousand
dollars oh that's more that's more
simple
i just have to do an impression of him
like on every podcast i think for young
kids that have been pursuing the
entertainment industry i was in
hollywood for like a decade too it's
scary what would you advise
god it's the wild west right now i mean
look i i mean i actually started losing
agents and managers they'd say
outright we can't help you because
you're white they'd email me they tell
me on the phone
the last manager that scouted me said we
aren't taking white men
it's a it's a real problem i'm not
saying some white men aren't going to
get in and and uh and by the way this
hurts everybody this isn't even about
white or black or brown or anything
because if you give someone a job who
isn't qualified in hollywood they're
gonna get eaten alive because it is a
brutal brutal business
but what i did this is just my own story
i just said screw it i started making my
own stuff
writing my own scripts
funded all of it i've made probably a
thousand videos at this point get
anywhere from a sketch to a one minute
thing
and that's how i got the the
my first movie role i've been acting for
17 years wow and uh so it i i hate to
say there's no real way to go right now
but uh they're certainly not looking for
talent
nope
just um
by checking out boxes i guess they know
when they see it they do yeah that's why
you put yourself out there yeah yeah
yeah i had to give up the dream i
actually had to kill the dream because i
started to get
booked on tv shows and bigger and bigger
roles and i thought oh now i'm going to
make a living and then it just came to a
screeching halt
and it was the woke ideology and they
weren't hiding it and so i said i have
to kill the dream do it myself and
that's it
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show however
you can take that url post it everywhere
and head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only show coming up at 11
p.m i imagine this will be funny and
we've got some stuff to talk about
that's
not so funny but uh we'll we'll get into
all that stuff we got matthew recap who
says i just watched what is a woman on
daily wire and i can't help but wonder
is there anything like what is a desired
what is a desired trait from back when
eugenics was a thing ps watch along
segment on timcast.com
that would be fun
i don't know when we have time to do it
is the challenge
yeah
nick koenig says first super chat just
chose vampires over the dawn guard in
skyrim 10th anniversary thoughts
ian just went to the bathroom so
unfortunately none
the wrong thinker says the atf has been
sitting on my form 4 for nearly a year
abolish gun control wow wow yup
that's how they do it
campbell of the mojave says it's weird
the daily wire hasn't secured the rights
to the story of that guy sitting in a
barber shop stands up to do the right
thing right that's a good point i agreed
that would be a crazy movie i i don't
know what you could really do with that
with that in terms of a plot though
you know
i guess you could you know they're
probably better they're better they are
better writers than i so
odysseus horse says tim have you looked
at getting
johnny b on he does a mix between gun
culture gun related politics and weapons
reviews he's also a big fan of your show
uh no but we will write down his name
we'll take a look
all right what do we got here
alessio de monte says speaking about gas
prices one store in montrose colorado
had 650 a gallon for diesel
wow
that's a kick in the balls man and
kicking the balls
i'm telling you right now
when the cost of working is greater than
what you make from the work the system
falls apart it's impossible i should say
this when the cost of working gets close
to the cost of uh what you earn what's
the point yeah because you're going to
be like i spend 10 bucks every day to
get to work and i make 11.
i just keep 10 bucks
you know i'm making one dollar back not
worth it
addison miller says tim listen to the
after show last night and as an alaskan
i can tell you the best thing about
anchorage is it's only 20 minutes to the
real alaska also 24-hour daylight is
only above the arctic circle but is a
real thing yeah it is i went to bergen
norway once and it was day out at
midnight it was like light out at
midnight
yeah
yeah it's like you got it aren't there
suicide rates really high in places like
that i think so yeah i was in iceland
too and you have you need black your
hotel needs blackout shades right of
people uh yes yeah reykjavik and uh but
it's a small place it's beautiful did
you go in the winter or the summer uh
i
i i don't remember oh it was new years
yeah it was winter oh yeah winter's wild
new year's that was cool we went to the
they had the big statue of that dude
whatever his name and i remember his
name is it lee ferriss george
probably i don't remember i don't think
it's lee ferriss new york
not bjork
but uh the craziest thing was i got
recognized
in iceland at a burger shop in the
middle of nowhere like it really was
like one guy no it's yeah so it was
halfway between reykjavik and some other
location so we're like seriously you go
outside and you see nothing like lava
rock or whatever and there's a burger
shop and then i walk in and it's just me
and a friend and then i order a burger
and then i'm sitting down eating and two
guys walk in and one guy goes oh hey
it's tim poole and i was like what
that's correct it's simple he's like a
server guy
i'm like yeah you're speaking english
this is weird i like it i was like this
guy's following me i think it is leigh
erickson or bardur snapfellas probably
big statue i don't know that was cool
though all their last names i think in
iceland are son or daughter yeah it's
interesting yeah if you look at the yeah
it's like daniel's son or you know
mock's daughter it's all son or daughter
that's correct
all right correct justin chavez says
shout out to the babylon bees what is a
man oh yeah
i watched the whole thing
all two minutes of the documentary and
the 45 minutes of credits lol
did they put something up gotta look at
that what is it man that's amazing
bad b says ask anyone who wants firearm
control how many lives have been saved
by firearms right yeah
jay says hey beanie band are you looking
uh into hiring video game players for
new culture shows or commentary
contracts security in california isn't
fulfilling in the slowly increasing
homeless population wears down your
empathy we aren't currently but it is
something we plan on doing soon
we're building a new building
and i'm hoping with the next two months
it's done but who knows we thought it
was been done way earlier but the steel
shortage has been kicking the balls i
did get starlink oh oh i hear yes not
set up yet not set up yet it's uh so
they launched starlink rv
which has no wait list
so we and that's what we needed we
needed like i wanted starlink because i
want to be able to mount it and use it
wherever we need to go so we can do you
know pork fest is coming up we're not
going to make it but if we want to do
any shows like that for the mobile
studio we need we need good satellite i
don't know if starling can handle it but
we just got it in the mail today so
we're going to do some test runs on it
that's going to be a lot of fun super
excited for that
did you see the chinese scientists call
for a plan to destroy starlink destroy
elon musk's starling this is from
livescience.com
crazy
ginger mac isaac says i just dropped
several clams for daily wire membership
to watch what is a woman excellent watch
it legit is and i'm so jealous worth it
i'm like we gotta we gotta make that we
gotta make what is an assault weapon
yeah yeah
that's a good one can you hire me i'll
shave and play ben shapiro perfect i'll
literally get like makeup to be ben
shapiro well we're gonna do it seriously
yeah i'll be serious
i'll be totally
well then you can have your great value
daily wire by subscribing at timcast.com
but we gotta get on that we've actually
discussed doing documentary stuff before
but
that the thing we're lacking is
managerial power that's the biggest
challenge
people who can make a machine move and
run we've got the people who can you
know fine-tune the machine or who can
hammer the widgets we need managers
that's a hard thing to find
and then the other you know we'll we'll
figure it out though we're getting there
all right what is this delamar says stg
44
sturm gur i'm saying that wrong probably
world war ii first assault rifle
different than military rifles at the
time defined as pistol grip shorter
rifle barrel select fire large magazine
smaller caliber caliber cartridge than
main military rifles at the time look up
the gun yeah i was reading about that
assault rifles typically referred to the
select fire capability
and
modern uh civilian variants don't have
that they're just semi-automatic it's
one one trigger per one one trigger pull
one bullet
agamemnon's gym bag says getting sick of
these bigoted gun phobes trying to
oppress us all gun control is racist
i i believe that it is true correct yes
yep
that is it is true
jason hunter says washington state
already takes longer than 72 hours to do
background checks i have a cpl and it
took a month to get a gun recently
that's what they're trying to do they
are eroding your ability to have guns
and they're hoping that within a
generation or two nobody has any
so they'll keep doing it but uh 3d
printers exist joe biden wants to make
3d 3d printed guns illegal but that's
stupid because it won't change the fact
that 3d printing guns will always exist
if someone wants one
let's see crispy leg
says
why does everyone forget that obama is
mixed race that's right he's white
yeah that's true obama's a white man
joe cub says ian mopping with two hands
had me rolling thanks but
okay
oh yeah mopping with two hands
ted says as a person of color it feels
like some people of color are more
people of color than other people of
color to democrats
same as 18 28 days
guy with nine fingers how about this tim
if the fbi fails to finish your
background check within 72 hours they
must cover the full cost of the firearm
you're attempting to buy agreed
um seconded yeah motion carries inserted
taxpayers yeah
free guns
double a says if trump came out for a
total ban on guns democrats would create
drive-through gunshots
there's your plan
that guy says raise minimum age for
firearm purchases to 21 due to prolonged
adolescence of current and future
generations and 21 for tobacco tattoos
sexual consent gender therapy and voting
rights compromised
yeah it was um ann coulter said i'm i'm
in favor of raising the gun age to 21 if
we raise the voting age to 21
and then it's like hmm
interesting
i went to a gun shop in virginia
and i was buying a bunch of guns and
this is crazy too because we live in the
tri-state so even when you buy them they
have to ship them
like drive 20 like 10 or 15 minutes and
then drop them off at your gun shop and
you got to pay the fee
but some some young guy came in to buy a
gun
and uh
they asked for his idea that you can't
buy handguns you're you're you're only
20 years old or whatever and then i was
like he's a 20 year old legal adult
who's got his own place to live and he
can't buy a handgun you know what i'm
starting to make sense we should maybe
raise the military age to 21. because we
have so many people in the country and
we do not need that many people in the
military now
i don't think sending a young 18 year
old it makes a lot of sense mentally
like we wouldn't send a 16 year old
because their minds aren't developed
that's why it makes sense unless they
identify as 21. well i don't know why
you're assuming that let's say i just
fixed it that was implicitly what i
meant to do
is 21. doesn't matter what age you are
you can go to war
all right villafear says tim i can't
think of a more badass backdrop than a
musket and samurai sword please don't
ever change it
i know originally it was a mall sword
yeah it was just like this goofy mall
sword i got for 10 bucks but everybody
was caught was making fun of them all
sword and then i was like still making
fun of me so i bought an actual wakazawa
which is actually it's like it's a real
one you know so it's cool it's like now
no one can make fun of me
yeah see take that guys yeah can't bully
me
no i don't know i just thought i ordered
one and i was like this kind of looks
better it's harder to fit but whatever
all right
the bee says vosh said he really wanted
to go toe-to-toe with me with matt walsh
on transgenderism you guys want to
moderate let's do it absolutely it'd be
fun all right there you go vosh matt
walsh you guys want to come on the show
and we'll have a conversation about
transgender kids dude matt knows what's
up
yeah i'll bring a couple kids oh no
live studio audience i mean that would
be that would be great i just think it's
it's it's it's a shame that vosh is like
the only leftists who's willing to come
on and actually debate these ideas yeah
i mean no good for him i disagree with a
lot he said creepy things have been
heavily criticized for that's true but
i will say there are a few other
there there's one particular other
person i'm not going to name who is not
welcome on the show but everyone knows
who he is but for the most part it's
like it's like pulling teeth to get
these people to come out and actually
debate these ideas is it bill maher
no bill maher we'll have bill maher on
the show absolutely
i wouldn't go on his show though
because i feel like
one of the challenges with going on
other people's shows
uh for bill in particular is that he
doesn't know what he's talking about
so i wouldn't want to be there with him
moderating and not knowing that would be
like a really bad position to be in
uh
the so going on joe rogan for instance
is always fantastic joe's great and joe
reads a lot but
when i said on his show last time in
november i think it was that uh most of
the country is now constitutional carry
joe said that can't be true and i was
like you know i'm pretty sure it is and
then he said jamie pull that up and
jamie pulled up a generic google search
that said 13 states and that's wrong
25. i was actually
mostly correct florida is about to pass
through the 26 states so when i was
saying that and i went oh i guess i was
wrong i'll eat that one wow i didn't
realize you're close so it's it's it but
but i'm not going to blame joe for that
i mean we you know we got it wrong bill
maher doesn't even fact check so being
on a show with him like you watch dennis
prager and he's like that viral clip
where he said they're putting tampons in
the men's room and bill goes no they're
not no it's not um i would not go on a
show like that like dude
bill
i think he's phoning it in like he
doesn't know what's going on he's only
somewhat realizing what's been happening
in the world he's 10 years he doesn't
write his ten dollars right he just
reads a monologue right exactly not
writing it and he's got a new podcast
and i'm just like i've had people reach
out and be like would you not from his
camp but people who are in the related
areas where like would you want us to
talk to them we would love to see you
and i'm like no way dude first of all
i'm not going to fly out there because i
got to do my show but more importantly
i'm just like as much as i can respect
him calling out a lot of this stuff
he's he's phoning it funny to watch you
he's so smarmy it's funny to watch him
against anyone who's like grounded okay
people the left the left is going too
far he talks like this the left is going
too far if the woke really want to
bounce they've lost their minds
it's just this real feminine this new
podcast called club random i haven't
heard it yet but i'm glad he's getting
away from the corporate crap yeah yeah
but you know i think the issue is he
grew up in a world where he just watched
cnn and that was the basis of his
reality
so he doesn't know
he was that's it he was wonderfully
outspoken in 2000 or 2002 2001 about
the iraq crap and like he was he was
really critical of george bush's
handling of that he's starting to crack
though now i think something is getting
to him slowly starting to crack yeah you
can see the light
bursting out of him all right leitzor's
says funny how ian starts mouthing off
about the catholic church the night
sheamus is good i would do it every
night
no he catholic cast
anybody who consistently watches the
show knows that ian says it right too
it's definitely the organization dude
the organization of the church is where
i have the issue i love god and the idea
of god and the consciousness and all
that and that that's where me and james
really get along
all right let's see
schneider strong says millennials don't
have the same number of children and
family as the boomer generation did
could this help explain why the younger
population would be okay with political
assassinations yes very good point
actually yeah older people are averse to
violence because um
what's that one movie uh with mel gibson
it's like the revolution the patriot
page that i reference all the time do
you like that movie i love that movie
it's good when mel gibson says he says
something like mark my words your
children will will learn of this war
this war will not be fought on a distant
far away battlefield that will be fought
in front of our homes your children will
learn about their own eyes correct and
that and then then he says something
like sir i have seven children i don't
have the luxury of you know what bravery
or something like that and then said
something about jews or something is
that a different movie
different movie no this one was actually
good
the the patriot man amazing movie i love
how they make the british people just
like the most detestable evil people
they got so mad about that who's the
who's the guy who uh plays the evil dude
i think his name is jason i don't
remember jason isaacs yeah yeah there
you go he was amazing and i love how
just he's like he's like very
one-dimensional he's like i'm going to
shoot a child
when it's like why would you do that so
smart like douglas mary she's like
douglas
evil douglas murray i love douglas
murray yes but it was cool though the
patriots like a revolution film freedom
and revenge so watching mel gibson you
know
win in the end is great
and then watching uh the regulars lose
and being like america
yes yeah like that fourth of july is
coming up that's right and that's maga
month july is officially maga month and
you we barbecue every weekend that's
right mega month mega month is july did
you not know that dude no yeah i thought
it was ultra mag a month oh yeah that's
for sure
no we were talking the other day about
pride month and then we were like when's
mega month and then i think lydia said
july yeah of course fourth of july
so the idea is for the entire month it's
just you barbecue that's right you know
wow that's what it's all about
yeah mag a month
i don't know what it's all about i'm
gonna we're gonna grill burgers yes
that's right mega month make july great
again they say sure
make july great again
bad b says equity is racist if you don't
understand how think about it till you
get it
was that meant to be grammatically
incorrect not sure
david c kronk senior says ian seems to
be stuck on this roman slavery point
without acknowledging the fact that the
egyptians enslaved the hebrews thousands
of years earlier yes slavery is not
endemic to the romans but the roman
empire is definitely endemic to our way
of life right now we need to shed
shatter that it's always been the crazy
thing was that like you could be not a
slave and then one day you could be a
slave like you're living in a village or
whatever and you're like working and
you're dealing with slavers and then one
day they just grab you and like you're a
slave now and you're like oh no like
what do i do
like that's crazy right
yeah you know that that culture was
brutal
oh snapple fact says tim politics are
one thing but i need the real question
answered sheets or wawa oh wow oh whoa
yeah
i'm unfamiliar i do like sheets though
that was groundbreaking so wawa also
lets you pre-order the
sub sandwich and then you they make it
on demand yeah is that similar to sheets
like that yeah wow was better
but we mostly have sheets out here yeah
sheets
yeah they're in the gas stations
awesome but they have like sandwiches
and stuff yeah they were the first place
i ever saw they had that like kiosk
ordering system at a gas station there's
a place in virginia i remember that did
deep like they did fried chicken and gas
there's a gas it was a gas station i
mean a lot of gas stations actually have
fried chicken if you think about it when
you're traveling around the country but
they like their whole marketing was like
fried chicken and gasoline or something
like that
so like you pump your while you're
pumping you walk in and they just drop
in the deep fryer that was awesome damn
i know like i will take some drumsticks
no today that would be a
yes
300.00
chicken and gas we're eating for the
month yeah
jeffrey faff says jordan peterson is
crying in joy right now tyler oh yeah
that's awesome
like there's no evidence of that
that's technically correct
christopher
scamra says love the impressions tyler
i've been trying to follow up with lydia
over email regarding a film pitch with
daley wire and dallas that almost got
greenlit tim before looking to
potentially make a project in
association with them we should talk
maybe
we we are doing a ton of infrastructure
stuff right now and there's a lot going
on well we've got to build we're
building a building and we're doing
we're working on the website and i'm
just like you know i wake up and i'm
like how do we make this stuff go faster
the problem is just
people
you gotta find people who know how to
build stuff yeah
yeah man i'll do the film though dm me
i'll do it yeah there you go
are you ready to do another one i'm
writing a movie now yeah that's the next
thing
yeah sam acts as you dare to speak ill
of the wars of stars how dare you how
dare you uh huh yeah star wars jumped
the shark along oh yeah episode one was
the terrible winner no no the prequels
were like
yeah the movie wasn't yeah that was the
problem the movies were stellar they
were so good four five and six return of
the jedi jabba the hutt luke skywalker
like the force is real
and
then they made jar jar binks and they
had liam neeson and ewan mcgregor and
they still screwed that movie up they
had natalie portman and the movie was
terrible because they had a cartoon
character as the lead and they had no
villain they had darth maul we had no
lines got slaughtered and you're like
what there was no villain the entire
series yep
yeah but the prequels i'm kind of just
like you know eh i gotta watch them yeah
i went to the theater that was like off
the worst the last jedi is probably the
worst film i have ever seen in my life
i'm not kidding
i i wanted to walk out of the theater
it was so bad
and i was like the only reason i didn't
was like i should finish it so i know
what happens
yeah and then and then you know what it
turns out so here's the thing about star
wars
they they said that um originally
with the prequels they were like star
wars is actually a series about darth
vader oh it starts with darth vader
and even throughout the prequels it's
about anakin skywalker it was a darth
vader story and then
and ends with his death and all that i
was like wow do you know what it is now
following the sequel films
the entirety of star wars is the story
of palpatine's gender transition stop
that's all it is
sign me up is this the one on w
have you guys seen the disney one the
one that gino was fired from mandalorian
oh that's man i saw a little bit of that
i've never seen it seen that it was good
so listen listen they said the story
started with darth vader right okay
let's think about where it ended right
now it ends with the emperor becoming a
young woman so
now it starts with palpatine as a
senator
trying to take over the government and
then ends with him trying to take over
the body of a young woman
and here's the thing right
this is this is true this is canon
spoiler alert in the end they find out
the emperor is actually alive
and he's like
you must strike me down so that i will
take over your body or something i'm not
for real like and then she's like no i
won't do it but then she does it
so like then she calls herself
skywalker or whatever but i'm like yo
the emperor walker you mean they them
walker yeah
imperial propaganda so so when the idea
was like he was going to live forever by
taking her body if she struck him down
in rage but then she strikes him down
anyway i'm like so he won but did she
like try to go down in rage but or was
it out of love i i think even the trans
community would agree that that's what
it's about
you have a good the emperor took over
the galaxy because he just wanted the
right body
some transparency isn't bill burn the uh
the mandalorian yes yeah
yeah that's so busy i was watching it it
was okay until there was a scene where
you know the guy played apollo creed was
in it he was like his his like handler
or something to give him these missions
and then there's a scene where he's
supposed to be given this real secret
mission he's like
okay your mission is yelling it out
everyone in the bar no it's the guy that
played apollo creed in the rocky movies
i don't know what his name is um and it
was just like who's directing this movie
i mean the guy is trying to be secretive
and he's yelling at everyone in the bar
about the secret it's how do you have
bill burr in it and cancel gina bill
says the craziest is he just yelling at
you you sound like bill are you doing a
big impression
i look at this [ __ ] right she's brutal
right leah's just bitching all the time
she's just yapping
yeah it sounds just like such a pleasure
all right let's read some more we got
john r he says make a flag for chicken
city
okay nice we will don't chicken on me
nate says did anyone who watched what a
woman noticed that the girl who swam
with leah thomas who was anonymous you
could clearly make out her face in the
close-up camera angle just making sure
i'm not crazy oh totally not crazy i
mean i just gotta say like if you send
me a video of someone and their voice is
altered i can easily correct that
oh really yeah and like ten seconds
it's really easy to do
because usually what they'll do is
they'll just pitch shift it right right
that worked back when at the average
person didn't have pitch shifting
software on their computer
but i mean the other thing too is like
cadence and
word choices you know who it is yeah
it's like you're anonymous it's like bro
i go to school with you i know that's
you
yeah it's like
come on you know that's not gonna work
huh
all right we'll grab a couple more
mima type says video ideas start with
the rainbow flag zoom out and add the
trans flag out uh tr add the trans flag
keep zooming out adding flags eventually
it zooms out to show a person's face
like they're rediscovering individuality
that's exactly what's gonna happen
rebel parish says i'm 410 and the guy
just needs to be taller than me i went
on a date sunday with a guy who was
literally the size of my 11 year old
niece same muscle mass wow
look i uh i didn't do yoga that week and
i was just slouching okay i'm sorry
sorry i'm having a rough week here
christopher mcketton says regarding the
polls about
damn young men and assassination versus
threats
the left thinks that words are violence
is uh the left thinks that word violence
is worse than actual violence maybe they
see the threat as an escalation from
physical
no they just don't want to warn you like
don't threaten them just do it just do
it damn
that sounds like a gang yeah damn young
man i'm a young man
[Laughter]
captain kirk oh wait we just jumped on
us no captain kirk disappeared super ted
is gone speak to me kirk all right brody
nevis says i was just told that alameda
county in california is going to have a
mask man it again this is stupid really
oh great wow sounds about right eden
hiddick says the anti-gun lobby has a
history of intentionally mislabeling
firearms and even attempted to label
handguns as pocket rockets
among other terms labeling every auto
weapon a machine gun is another amazing
yup here we go captain kirk says tim i
hope people realize we can't vote
democrat anymore we have to vote
republican but democrats aren't uh we
don't have to vote republican but
democrats aren't the way and their party
knows it
i mean i'm i th
libertarian party yeah dave smith
actually the libertarian the mises
caucus just swept the libertarian party
uh michael males just had the was it the
chairman of the libertarian party on
you're welcome angela yeah mm-hmm
that's very promising those guys are if
you were actually at the libertarian
national convention like i was you
wouldn't feel it was as promising oh
really what was it like it was crazy it
was crazy i mean i'm happy that the
mises caucus took over but um when the
whole body of a thousand delegates
couldn't decide on when to go to lunch i
lost all hope yeah yeah it was it was
like half and half not authoritarian
enough yeah oh yeah it was tough you get
a bunch of libertarians in a room it's
tough to make a decision
yeah well just tell everybody to take
care of themselves there you go oh yes
lunch go eat when you feel like eating i
don't care that would be the libertarian
point of view theoretically speaking but
an action that did not play out that way
yeah it was crazy stephen l says it's my
birthday happy birthday stephen stephen
joseph henson says funny thing in
retrospect is that when you add up the
issues we're facing who's causing the
most noise and the ideologies involved
turns out that legalizing prostitution
when australia did would have saved the
world hmm
why i don't get it why am i missing
i don't understand yeah that eluded me
too i'm not sure prostitution that's all
i heard yeah pretty much
mad make says make a participation flag
for the salty army please well i
couldn't make the flag they'd have to
make the flag yeah right i don't want to
make a flag for somebody else you know i
would i would miss it represent you know
cultural appropriation man but i'll tell
you what you can do you can smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if you
do like it and head over to timcast.com
become a member right now if you haven't
already we're gonna have a members only
show coming up at 11 p.m it's going to
be a whole lot of fun you can follow the
show at tim cast irl follow us on
instagram we have clips every day you
can follow me at timcast basically
everywhere tyler do you want to shout
anything out sure tie the fish i'm
shadow band everywhere so i got to spell
it out you got to write the whole thing
t y the fish f-i-s-c-h
and tylerfisher.com uh i'll be touring
the country doing stand up soon so you
can sign my email list and youtube tyler
fisher
nice head over to timcast.com and check
out the read
little uh in the left-hand side check
out the read you're gonna find some
awesome journalism there right now you
can follow me in crossland.net and you
get in touch with me through social
there and i want to just shout out tara
on the prairie which is yeah yeah i'm
going to be coming out gina carano nick
cersei cowboy cerrone on june 14th on
the daily wire we're going to do a q a
uh on the premiere night very cool yeah
yeah all right man good to see you yeah
thanks for having me here's my moment of
truth i tweaked my camera a little bit
without looking at it there we go i'm
still here still in the corner thank you
guys very much for tuning in this
evening with tyler i had a blast i'm
really looking forward to the bonus show
you guys may find me on twitter and
mines.com at star patchlets as well
sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you